foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
daddy this should be remixed if officer
akimov is watching this could be the
next remix Masterpiece dude because just
wait till you see what happens here oh
officer officer akimov is here uh that's
beautiful
[Music]
who's your dad I'm joined today by
Pastor James David Manning
no I'm a Christian
[Music]
your dad I'm joined today by Pastor
James David Manning
[Music]
a long-legged Mack Daddy is the most
successful death on planet Earth to
reverence the word of God to trust it to
preach it to teach it
Loaves and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies what happened in prison
that brought you to Jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to Jesus
[Music]
and George Bush Jr have been penetrated
by at least 100 men and their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong I didn't do it that's not my
problem well I got down on my knees
[Music]
I didn't do it I was tempted sounds like
quite an evening
and tons and tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies
[Music]
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
and loads of money and tons and tons of
Lies
I didn't say something to you about
marketing
Starbucks has done the exact same thing
that Coca-Cola has done except they've
done it we've seen it that certainly it
seems to be a story that has been missed
[Music]
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
and bathrooms
[Music]
bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
sure is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
this is
[Music]
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude he is gone ladies and
gentlemen Alex Jones is now very very
upset with me look at that that is a
freaking Predator right there
smarter than you think she's better than
you and he's gonna beat you Pac-Man
never talked to the New World Order
because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is gone
[Music]
to me
[Music]
[Music]
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you
hahaha
[Music]
I have with me David Pacman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and TV program The
David packman show sure and I wanted to
talk to David Pacman he is a baby of
male
David Patman he is
[Music]
David Pac-Man he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic
and that's a beta man they go along with
homosexuality hold on Buddy
that's a lot that's a lot we win
everything that's raw abortion they they
can act just like a woman a beta
Marathon
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they are controlled by the darkness
of David Patman he is
[Music]
a baby girl
David Patman he is a baby
[Music]
hey
[Music]
David Pac-Man here's a baby girl
David you're not here to communicate I
really appreciate you coming on I'm
going to let you go to waste of time to
talk to you we're not communicating
you're actually like that because you're
asking bizarre questions
and you wasting my time I'm preaching
all right tonight
[Music]
[Music]
I love mangoes too
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes like
three boxes
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified
sure
[Music]
mangoes will a very warm welcome
everybody we are standing by for a
marginally more important Trump rally
tonight we are now really in the thick
and in the long and in the wide of the
2022 midterms and maybe one of the most
important races is the Pennsylvania
Senate race over on the Democratic side
John fetterman who is my choice although
his last debate performance was not good
not good he's still my choice from the
standpoint of policy John fetterman has
opened up a pretty powerful lead on the
Democratic primary side on the
Republican side it's kind of tight and I
have the numbers here a TV doctor named
Mehmet Oz has now surged into
first place I guess
um and in second places a businessman
Dave McCormick
Kathy Barnett in third place Carla Sands
well behind
Bartos the least crazy of the candidates
in fifth place and then two candidates
who I've never even heard of because
they don't even make it onto the stage
butchetto and Gail
Barrel they're like in the Tulsi level
of polling so it is actually a fight and
tonight we are uh Dr Oz just spoke
Mehmet Oz sorry Mehmet Oz just spoke and
Trump is expected to you know very
powerfully endorse him if he can
remember his name Trump sometimes
forgets the names of the people he
endorsed we endorsed JP right JD Mandel
um but the expectation of the belief is
that the Maga or Maga or magat crowd
the maggots
they are not big on Mehmet so the rumor
is like they're gonna boo tonight maybe
even as loudly as they booed vaccines
last time Trump suggested that they're a
good idea to get
so
um that's going to be tonight and it's
going to be very interesting now we do
have a bit of a glitch which is as you
can see it's pouring in uh wherever
where are they I have the weather
forecast it's pouring in
Greensburg Pennsylvania we have very we
have massive dumps of rain
and it's expected to rain for the
foreseeable future and one of the things
we've learned is that Trump doesn't like
it when it rains and that may be a
Saving Grace for us from the standpoint
of trump may keep the rally very very
short because Trump doesn't like going
out in the rain it causes real problems
for his hair
uh he just seems not to like it and so
it's having more of a Woodstock feel so
far uh really then uh than anything else
so welcome everybody uh bay photo says
via Super Chat it is very wet from the
standpoint of water surrounded by water
big water ocean water exactly super
chats dumping in Andrew says cheers to
another evening of unhinged lunacy
hopefully we get more slides and graphs
yeah at Trump's last rally the crowd was
truly riveted when Trump put up an
extremely detailed graph with small font
uh gamer says that intro is the greatest
hits JP Wright JD Mandel Billy the cud
trothed Central Obama stupid or a
dictator right I actually have a new
page
Trump glitches so much and so badly that
I now have a glitches page so I can talk
through it like for example once Trump
tried to name a company and here's what
he said
[Music]
and then on another day Trump tried to
talk about voting drop boxes no more the
drop boxes and then on another day Trump
tried to name the country to our South
Max silicone and then once Trump tried
to name someone from history I've had
more investigations than Jesse James
Billy the could one day Trump got former
President Obama's name wrong Obama and
then on another day Trump got his own
name wrong then anyway Donald Trump
killed Donald Trump and then on another
day Trump made up the name of someone
that he thought he had endorsed we've
endorsed JP right JD Mandel and then on
another day Trump got the name of his
own social media platform wrong truth
essential and then
and then on another day Trump got the
name of Mitt Romney wrong a rhino named
Mitt Romney and then Trump on one day
tried to promote pronounce Indian names
and it was not good
yeah and then Trump signed off and God
bless the United States that's really
quite it's it's actually let me see if I
can even show this I have my little
stream Deck with me today
uh it's essentially a full page I don't
know if that plays let me see if I can
yeah
it's I have I have an entire page
dedicate dedicated just to glitches
that's when you know it's bad
um okay
oh I have a new technical element which
I have to tell you I am so pleased with
some of you are aware that we're in the
middle of building a new studio
and one of the things about the new
studio in in New York is that during a
period of time when I'm in the the new
studio for now we're using a green
screen because things are happening
behind the green screen and I'm on the
green screen right now
which is what's incredible and some of
you noticed that down over there things
weren't looking right
uh and that's true because of the lights
I have here they were not properly
lighting the green screen down there so
I added a third light and look at the
difference it makes without that light
can you see how it's a little bit
glitchy here and the reason for that is
that the green screen just isn't lit
enough there let me see if I can even
show you
uh
I guess I can't do that anyway so down
there it's a little glitchy today I am I
now have a third floor light and look
what it does
beautiful
it's it's just such a I love lighting I
really do it's such a great technical
element
um and then some of you also noticed
that the
um
audio was a little echoey here
and so what I did I don't know if you're
going to be able to see this I brought
in
these sound panels
see this
and if we really wanted to do it right I
could even
we wanted a more intimate feel
we could set ourselves up like this
hoodie for a fireside chat
uh so we've got that and I keep it just
off camera
let's see here
there we go
and we've dealt with the echo I mean
really it's it's just it's a dramatic
Improvement I guess is what I would say
Okay so we're back anyway enough tech
people were bored by Tech other super
chats coming in is it safe to assume
Newsmax isn't covering this uh no
Newsmax I believe is covering this
actually I believe they are and we're
monitoring Newsmax very strongly
what's the over under on Trump blaming
the Reign on Biden's radical socialist
regime I would say 50 50.
it's hard to take maggots seriously when
they criticize Biden's cognitive
function given how bad trumps always is
true
my two favorite glitches are Mitt Romney
okay hold on I think I've got that Mitt
Romney a rhino named Mick crime neighbor
I like that ER and then the drock box no
more the Dropbox is it do you think this
Supreme Court leak will give the
Democrats the kick they need to create
to keep the crazy conservatives in the
minority
That's My Hope
if so do you think enough time will pass
for the crazy Republicans will fade away
I just don't know
David sir do you think this record
record-breaking crowd will breach a
million from the standpoint of
attendance this is the biggest crowd not
just of any Trump rally of any rally
that there's ever been
let me thank some people
oh wow I missed a lot of thank yous I
want to say thank you for signing up via
twitch Prime to Harry
bobafetra Hippie Chick Jason Melton Jane
here sorry Jen here Papa Bear Kenzo
David Gilmore and Chuck nezi
that puts us at six
beautiful
also a big thank you to Tyler
stooksberry who just signed up at
joinpakman.com you're number seven today
and also Kevin gouldi sending in another
gifted subscription as well as David
Marquis that puts us at nine and I'll
give away two memberships Dan Katz gets
a membership and Samuel Summerhill gets
a membership if you've been thinking of
requesting a membership we are this is
today's the ideal day to do it because
there's only 652 people waiting ahead of
you often the number swells
um all like Trump's eyes all the way
over 700 we are now down thanks to so
many gifts to only 652 people waiting
for memberships and you can put your
name in at davidpackman.com slash free
membership
okay let's get into some material oh
hold on but there's a few things check
out Tesla's 2021 impact report okay
since you're doing Greatest Hits can we
get Trump's sir sound I actually now
have
uh I call this Mega sir sure sure sure
sure
sure sure
sure yeah
Larry says hey David here's what I was
talking about the other day prepare
thyself so glad I've been able to catch
most of your live streams anymore
the Wiki page for positive anymore oh
wow yeah that's not a that's not a
grammatical element I use Larry
sir will the machines in your new studio
be sued by the crackhead pillow salesman
we're doing a class action
all machine
Andrew says David can I can't give God a
super chat for raining so heavily on
these people so you can have it love the
show thank you Andrew I really
appreciate that that's an important
thing okay let's get to some stuff okay
do you guys want stuff here are our
friends over at the good liars this is
our friend again I don't know what this
guy's real name is I know his handle on
social media is DAV Ram
I I just I don't know his name but he
does great interviews this is one of my
favorites you guys might have seen the
recent video audio rather of uh Kevin
McCarthy saying we've got to get rid of
trump we've just got to get rid of the
guy
and Dav RAM and the good liars found
this gentleman and I used that term
loosely
who believes that the the the McCarthy
audio is made up and the guy lacks the
cognitive capacity to explain what he
means by made up
check this out this this is actually
brilliant work check this out people are
asking about January 6th over the last
couple days it's been in the news a lot
why don't they make a big
they're Biden it seem to me like that's
a lot bigger deal than January the 6th
Kevin McCarthy was on tape saying he was
going to ask Donald Trump to resign why
do you think he did that
I don't know if that's even real but
what do you mean I don't know I don't
even know if it's real or not but if it
is what do you mean that it's not real
do you mean
sir I don't know if that tape's even
real or not by not real what it would
what do you mean
I probably made up or something
now if it like so if it were me
obviously the tape's real
but if I'm gonna claim it might not be
real I would be prepared to say it could
be a deep fake it could be McCarthy's
voice but it's chopped up it could be
that it's not even really McCarthy it's
a voice actor or whatever but this guy's
like it might not be real like but what
do you mean it might not be real he's
like I don't really know
made up like
like how
oh man that's bad that's really really
bad
just scary scary stuff
super chats keep coming in uh hold on I
think I missed one
David I need to know those Psychiatry oh
physiatrists and or doctors who spoke to
you about Trump did they say if the Sur
stories are a side effect of his alleged
mental problem sure no they did not they
didn't mention that
Allen says I just closed on a house in
Marjory Green's District this morning to
be closer to family tell me it's going
to be okay it's probably going to be
okay yeah
it'll Pro I guess I mean I don't know
uh thanks to Christy and joy Kitt for
the uh getting a weird hair thing for
the twitch Prime subscriptions numbers
10 and 11. welcome everybody uh so so
glad that you're here I am very very
briefly made it onto MSNBC you might
remember I recently interviewed a guy
named J.R Majewski he's a trump endorsed
Republican who won his primary in a
little compilation Ari melber on MSNBC
featured me for about a second you've
got it if you blink you'll miss it guys
okay check this out right now we're
getting into how these new primaries
this week are advancing what looks like
a takeover of the GOP by conspiracy
theorists in January 6 rally attendees
I decided to raise as much money as I
could within the three-day period to
take as many people to DC as I could I'm
the only candidate in this race
that the president had to admiration for
it's like antifa and BLM were funding
riots and fueling fires to burn down our
city everybody hold your blinks so you
don't miss me on MSNBC okay if you blink
you'll miss it please eyes open while
left-wing liberals hey they're bail I
think the election was stolen personally
oh man the royalty checks are gonna be
coming in guys very very quick quick
moment there
um how many Gift subscriptions have been
given so far okay let's find out
you guys want to guess how many how many
subscriptions do you think have been
gifted ever on my website we only put it
in place like
I think about a month ago I'm gonna look
it up right now
zero well no it's obviously not zero
350.
350 may not be bad actually there's a
lot of people here who might be pretty
close
sinsu wants to know what's the total
number of gifts including mocking owl
who just gifted one which is number 12
today and that one goes to Michael Keane
the total number of gifts is
see I've got to go into
a lot of people in the 250 range
let me see the the actual number gifted
is
that is tight okay gifts purchased let's
take a look here
315 315 memberships have been gifted
since we launched it uh which isn't bad
it's a it's a fraction of what's been
gifted on Twitch because Fitch from the
beginning has had those elements
um but 315 is actually I got to be
pretty happy with that
yeah Jen here on Twitch
is in fifth place and is within Striking
Distance of moving into fourth place
which is pretty wild all right let me
continue let's look at some things
happening at the Trump rally Ron
filipkowski has a bunch of different
different things here's Mehmet uh here's
soaking wet Mehmet Oz
talking about I guess firing fauci I
don't know Trump
oh we're better than that and we're
going to make sure that we stand up in
their face and we'll fight back are you
willing to fight China
will you fight for our kids in our
schools
are you gonna fight back to keep our
borders clean
you're gonna fight back to make sure we
don't have Falcons you want to fire
fouchie
I thought that would get you worked up
this election
yikes
pretty bad
Dinesh D'Souza in an oversized coat and
white hoodie looking as disheveled as
I've ever seen him spoke at the rally
and paid ballot trafficking
in some states it is legal ballot
trafficking they're just making stuff up
now ballot trafficking Matt Gates was
found with underage ballots stuffed in
his boxers it was crazy
to give someone else your ballot and
have them drop it off usually the
conditions of that are kind of specified
they're clear in Georgia for example you
can give your Mallet to a family member
or if you are in a confined facility you
can give it to a caregiver
but in no state in no state is it legal
and
yikes a lot of really weird stuff there
uh see if we have anything else from the
rally
pillow announces at the rally that Doug
Wardlow his general counsel for the
pillow business is running for attorney
general I said hey would you like a job
with my pillow so he came up just say
mind pillow
did he say mind pillow I need to hear
that again
I said hey would you like a job with my
pillow so he came on with my pillow he's
been amazing and and uh with actually
Lindell management by which manages all
my other stuff but he is now part of
these preliminary injunctions and
preliminary Junction and I want to talk
to her so Doug why don't you absolutely
you could not thank you Mike
yeah hey Mike very good finally I can
and ask questions because I don't even
have to ask Mike questions he just he's
ready to he's ready to go so some people
call it uppers pillow says every dime of
his pillow company takes that is take
takes in is now spent to reinstate Trump
that seems dumb he's now I mean you name
it it's uh everything's on sale today
this is uh I mean this this is a a very
important day all these rallies are so
important because it gets the word out
so if you guys want to support both rsbn
myself my pillow everything towels that
work are towels that don't work a big
issue
like I guess I could think about once I
was at a very cheap hotel
and the towels were kind of like
cardboard I guess in a sense they didn't
work but I didn't know non-functioning
towels was an issue we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines okay
hmm anti-az mood at the rally of course
you've got the Oz race we talked about
that earlier uh what's your thoughts on
that race I mean you know how if you
don't want to share them right now I'm
just curious as someone who's running
for another office here in this state uh
is Dr Oz best for the state of
Pennsylvania I'm not there uh I'm not
there with us the left-wing statements
are too recent wow I love this
that I love to see okay so that's Ron
philipkowski uh we're going to look at
some other Clips in a moment I do want
to say thank you over on Twitch to
snortzie winklebottom R Rhino for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
15. I also want to say thank you to
Bryce Arnold who just gifted a
membership on my website as well as
Jennifer Devoe those are number 16 and
17. the winners of those free
memberships are Karen Fritz and Chris
Amos if you'd like a free membership do
not email me do not leave a voicemail do
not send a special delivery carrier
pigeon
uh just go to davidpackman.com free
membership let's look at some of these
super chats that are coming in Larry
says it shouldn't be used by anyone okay
more of this English stuff Neil Postman
was his mentor and friend okay wow
that's a lot that's a lot going on there
Jake says it's been raining here in
Pittsburgh all day hope it's just as bad
there and the failed ex-president
doesn't show I think it'd be amazing if
Trump does like a five-minute rally
because he hates the the water
hold on I think I actually have a bunch
of different water Clips surrounded by
water big water ocean water yeah
that might be it as far as water
dumps oh yeah dumps of water okay David
your video about Candace Taylor was
terrifying she's a new level of nuts
yeah if you haven't seen that I
encourage you to check it out
I don't usually comment on videos of
trump supporters being interviewed but
that made me sad I have the same speech
problems as the guy from the interview
on the bad Liars I I don't think that
guy a guy had a speech problem
he just didn't know what he was talking
about
he was saying the video might be fake
without even knowing what that meant
Benjamin dropping in a huge forty dollar
Super Chat says David thank you for
highly improving my critical thinking
skills on politics these last few days
seriously on that note do you think the
Roe v Wade law has a chance to stay as
is it seems pretty clear that they're
getting rid of Roe v Wade so at this
point I cannot say it's likely to stay
as is no
I don't think so
but
you know
it ain't over till it's over I think is
what the kids these days say
let's um let's watch a few other things
that I have other clips from the rally
so far
uh oh I guess JD Vance spoke he's just
gross
um Oz asks if we're gonna keep our
borders clean face and we'll fight back
are you willing to fight China
will you fight for our kids oh we saw
that clip earlier
you know what this rain is this is God's
tears that Biden is president
[Music]
oh terrorist audio
[Music]
Joe ladies and gentlemen Joe Biden
doesn't belong in the white house he
belongs in a nursing home at Camilla
Harris belongs in a Nut House
Camella jeez yeah cause this guy sounds
with it right the guy I'm listening to
these clips and tell me if this sounds
like a gentleman who's with it we've
endorsed JP right JD Mandel
no more dropped by the Dropbox this is a
cepha hide a rhino named Mitt Romney
original
Obama then he went Donald Trump yeah
Donald Trump like silicone I've had more
investigations than Jesse James Billy
the could yeah Billy the could that
guy's suit definitely sounds like he's
with it so
something we'll be looking at very very
strongly uh that may be it as far as uh
clips from the rally I mean the rain is
really making it not as raucous of an
event as it usually is
um
let's see over here if we've got
anything
from the rally
here's another Mehmet element which I
don't think we really need Vance we
don't care about today we already did
this one
a lot of people retweeting that
coveted nonsense from Oz
the entire crowd sitting yeah I think
that Oz may get booed when Trump brings
him up I think it could very much happen
hmm
[Music]
wow really weird videos but I guess
Republicans don't like him because he
sort of like seemed to say vaccines are
good that can make you persona non-grata
um
yeah let's listen in a little bit I
thought we'd take a few minutes to talk
about the history of the media in this
country and that's okay we're not going
to listen to right side broadcasting
tell us the history of the media that
I'm going to say uh that's a no for me
Doug thanks to RSG for the twitch Prime
subscription you're number 18. I very
much appreciate that uh now I see when I
looked at that Tick Tock video a lot of
people are saying Tick Tock videos are
just bad we're actually doing really
well on Tick Tock from the standpoint of
the David Pacman show we now have a
hundred and one thousand followers on
Tick Tock we haven't gotten to a hundred
thousand followers this quickly on
literally any platform we've ever been
on and uh we're we're really growing our
audience it's a younger audience than we
have on any other platform we're
reaching new people some of our Clips
there have half a million views so we're
tick I'm a fan I'm a fan of tick tock
are your tick tocks and YouTube charts
the same contact content yes they are
how many texts have I pointed out on
Tick Tock yeah I've never done that I've
never done that that's a little bit
cringy I admit all right man okay let's
go to a few voicemails while we have
time here here from some folks in the
audience and uh see what is on people's
minds I guess is what we would say
there's a lot of really crazy voicemails
I get
um let's see hi David you seem like a
relatively fit and healthy guy seems
like your body mass index is probably in
the normal range I'm usually sell a lot
of like supplements and uh kind of
plant-based products which I believe is
I sell supplements or no or this guy
says he he uses supplements
I don't know what he's talking about uh
the healthiest uh diet that has a lot of
plants so my question for you is what is
up with this cheese butter I mean like
what are you trying to do to me David
I'm already fat
yeah that stuff is pretty good that I I
listen
let's not allow the the War on Drugs
people to find out about that cheese
butter because uh that stuff is
genuinely addictive let's not even say
anything else about it because it could
I don't want to get anybody addicted to
that uh in who who shouldn't and they're
they're a great Advertiser it's actually
great stuff
um all right let's see what else we've
got here
uh
uh comment on my interviews with
conservatives man this one weird hair
here I'm really having an issue with it
hey David uh I'm a new fan
um I'm enjoying your interviews with uh
these conservatives running for office
these Trump conservatives thank you I
would like it if you would ask them a
question
um since they seem to believe that the
election was stolen in Georgia I don't
know how they believe that
um it'll be good if you can ask them if
they accept the results of Marjorie
Taylor greens yeah I know I know I know
the idea which is like how can you say
if you accept all the other races then
how is it only the Trump Biden was rig
yeah that's that's a fair that's a fair
thing and we've dealt with that Jack
says David sir can you say hello to my
girlfriend Erica who's watching hi Erica
and two play The Dr Oz ad on guns oh
yeah yeah yeah I've heard of that let's
see Oz guns let's see if we can find it
I haven't seen it
my father taught me how to handle my
first gun I taught my son Oliver how to
do the same I've been shooting hunting
my whole life so when people say I won't
support guns
they're dead wrong
other conservatives know that I'm strong
on a second amendment Ted Nugent
repairing president Trump Nugent knows
about it wow but our Second Amendment is
not just about hunting it's about our
constitutional right to protect
ourselves from inconstitutional Tutors
or an overly intrusive government so as
your next U.S senator I will fight for
our constitutional rights
oh it doesn't seem like his ex like he
feels
super at ease in that it seems a little
bit forced
thanks to reality defiler and Alpha
Omega for the twitch Prime subscriptions
I appreciate that Alpha Omega asks could
the Roe v Wade leak be a tactic to
potentially disqualify a sitting judge
if Republicans get the midterms and
retake Congress they could stall
nominations until 24 in the hopes a
republican nominee wins the White House
further swinging the court to 7-2 I
don't think so I don't think so
is Dr Oz's statement that he has foreign
policy experience because the show is on
in different countries better or worse
than Palin's statement in 08.
um
wow that's really tough Palin said
something like her foreign policy
experience is that you can see Russia
from Alaska Oz said he has a lot of
knowledge of other countries because his
show is on in a hundred countries
damn they're both pretty bad
I don't know which one is worth worse
David circan you post a link to that
fabulous elements of bathroom song in
the chat my children are begging to hear
it right now man I don't know do you do
you mean this one
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
I don't I don't I actually don't know
how to find it
I don't know how to find it
uh
I'll have to I'll have to look
yeah sorry about that yeah I'm just not
sure
I want to say thank you to Danielle
Dantzler for uh subscribing at
joinpakman.com and giving away the
membership that membership goes to
Suzanne McNeil Suzanne congratulations
uh you have just earned by not doing
anything actually you've earned a free
membership
and you've done nothing for it
which is totally fine you don't need to
do anything that's the whole point would
you say if Trump endorsed McCormick he'd
run away with it and since he chose Oz
who is too recently left-wing it gives
the Democrats oh uh John fetterman a
better shot well let's just let's just
wait and see I don't know
it would be great
Philly and Pittsburgh have the biggest
voter base in the state so why are these
candidates avoiding the big cities good
question I don't know
it's a fair question
I want to say a thank you wow a lot of
gifted Subs coming on Giovanni Castro
has just gifted a membership that is
number 22 today the lucky recipient
there is Bobby Graves Bobby Graves let's
do a couple other voicemails
um
let's see who I've got here
voicemails voicemails voicemails
hey David it's Franny um from Chicago
I'm a super fan wow I don't think I've
ever had a Super Fan before
and I just want
to watch laning inflation rates what
raising
um the uh interest rates really is and
by board and why it affects us the house
double edged stored all of it was just
so [ __ ] great whoa thank you for that
segment and please keep segments like
that coming
love it love it love it love it
uh here's another one
hey David so I don't know if anybody is
really showing enough appreciation for
the title of your videos I think they're
absolutely hilarious nobody is showing
enough appreciation for the titles of my
videos yeah that's actually it's correct
and it's depressing I need more
appreciation for the titles I come up
with
um especially the ones with Trump so
sweaty Trump I'm reading these off of
the computer right now sweaty Trump's
interview goes horribly wrong sweaty
dangerous cult leader Trump
sweaty Trump's delusional interview
horrified the world
Trump incoherent glitches badly during
sweaty Fiasco
glitches badly during sweaty Fiasco you
know what's really funny
we'll sometimes have like a review with
our YouTube rep and you know it's like
it's all very professional like he'll
come in with he'll fly in with a laptop
to make a presentation to me and
sometimes he'll go like Clips with high
engagement he'll go you know one of the
things I noticed about this clip Trump
mispronounces everything as Indian crowd
flees was that people were staying
through to the end of the video and
that's really interesting and I just
can't even take seriously the fact that
we're having like it's it's up on us
when I went to Google
the titles were up on a huge screen they
were like yeah you know uh Trump
glitches badly at incoherent Fiasco did
a lot better than Fox News silent as
Ivermectin and shambles it was a very
interesting thing
um seeing these things in a professional
context is weird that's for sure
thanks to good Baker and also thanks to
Alpha Omega for gifting for
subscriptions four plus one is five five
plus 22 is 27.
which I really appreciate also want to
say thanks to Donald Richards who just
gifted one on my website that one goes
to Zach Bassem bassham
uh would you save oh okay that one I
answered all right hey fellow Canadians
who are the best YouTubers for Canadian
politics I will leave that to the
Canadians to answer
I cannot say for sure
uh let's listen to a couple other ones
blurring the shovel Trump's worst rally
in years
I mean I don't know if
I mean who's not satirical by the way I
I genuinely think they're actually just
really funny I'm a big fan of the show
um but I don't know if you name these
titles but I am coming up with the
titles yeah they're hilarious I like I
like the little component of Comedy that
you add to the title of the videos and
sometimes to the the videos themselves
so yeah sometimes people will go David
some of these titles are a little too
exaggerated but like that's exactly the
point that's it's it's it's just a joke
now
uh that's all it is that you know
sometimes people take themselves and my
what what I do a little too seriously
it's at the end of the day it's just
like I'm just giving my opinions and
some people are interested in that and
that and some aren't but like you know
David you would you shouldn't really
mention that Trump was swollen in the
titles doesn't it doesn't really it's
not becoming of a journalist and it's
like I'm not a journalist I'm just a
commentator that's all it is
Okay let's listen to a couple of others
any moment Trump will be speaking
so I noticed that you changed your like
wardrobe shirts like a skew of colors
and um a skew of colors write you an
email about uh that which was really
cool
um so it looks like your eyes are like
Gatorade color like you make me want to
like take that like icy whitish Gatorade
and like the blue ice and mix it
together and it's like I have green eyes
that's weird I don't know like a gray
kind of feather or something like that
wow like uh getting a little thirsty in
here
you know uh Sky Vibes which is cool
um
on behalf of like the art committee uh
that's a proud moment of
um accomplishments for myself I actually
scored like 106 on the IQ test oh that's
a beautiful that's nothing to be ashamed
about Whitney 106 is a beautiful score
beautiful nothing uh nothing wrong with
that
okay so that's uh that's Whitney
um hello kintu asks do you think you'll
ever suffer from the immense jealousy of
never being a trump Gold Card owner yeah
Don Jr was offering Trump gold cards
recently if Trump wins 24 do you think
the blue States succeed well I assume
you mean secede but if Trump wins in 24
I would bet on Blue rather than red
states to succeed for sure Adam says hey
David former Republican and huge fan of
the show will a true Progressive ever
become president of the United States I
believe the answer is yes
I believe the answer is yes although I
don't know when
but someday
a true Progressive will indeed
be president
people are telling me Ron philipkowski
posted a few more things from the rally
no I'm not seeing that let's see hold on
Trump rally and let's see what we can
find
so we looked at pillow already we looked
at that clip we looked at that
Front Row Joe says he arrived at the
Trump rally a week ahead of time did you
get here yesterday and who of your
friends got here the earliest for
today's rally I don't know who got here
the earliest but the earliest is like a
week ago
so like Monday Rick Frazier actually
he's been here a week on Monday so
that's that's uh logical
Mike Lindell
[Music]
oh God it really looks like Woodstock
that is that is wild
Trump supporters boo Dr Oz
[Music]
yeah
wow
this is like a particularly depressing
rally I don't know why maybe it's the
weather there but it's extra depressing
yeah it's like what else do you show up
a week early to even if I'm going to a
great conference I show up the day
before you know
a week early Trump was at a different
rally a week ago very strange very very
strange
you're just joining us this rally is in
Pennsylvania
um we will see whether trump pronounces
it Pennsylvania or Pennsylvania
or some other way I mean at this point
the pronunciation stuff is is weird a
rhino name rhyme name no more
silicone yeah
so uh we'll have to we'll have to watch
that
um let's see what oh we were doing
voicemails yeah let's do just a couple
more I'm not going to belabor the
voicemails because a lot of them are
pretty weaponized
but sometimes there's a good one
oh here's troll man let's see what he
has to say trollman actually does gift
subscriptions to people so I'll I'll
entertain it hey David Swan
so about this abortion situation
um
I want to add a
a piece to the puzzle and that is
the whole thing of equity
so
if a woman
wants to have an abortion
or wants to have the child okay she can
choose freely
without any issue okay
however
if the man or the person that
participated in that pregnancy
doesn't want to have the child
or would like to have that child aborted
it doesn't seem like he has much
leverage leverage leverage to force a
woman to make to have a medical
procedure
is it normal for men to have leverage to
force women to have medical procedures
that's kind of weird
she could override his wishes and
decision
and force him to
have the child and be responsible for it
did she force him to impregnate her
this is weird
um both parties were involved in the
behavior that led to that reproduction
of the child right
so how is that fair
yeah I don't think it's fair
it doesn't apply to me because uh
I don't have a responsible
relationships but that's not surprising
to me Juan with all due respect it's
based on your phone call history it's
not shocking to me that you're not in a
relationship right now
that isn't that isn't coming as a
surprise
is it fair that the woman calls all the
shots when it comes to whether or not
she has a child I think what you're
asking is should the man be able to
force the woman to have a medical
procedure
which is uh weird
which is weird man that's that's
something Juan we love you buddy but uh
wow wow wow wow
thanks to nasty questions for the twitch
Prime subscription you're number 29
today Pappy says sorry do you believe
they will succeed from the union Pappy
the word is secede
s-e-c-e-d-e that was the joke but that's
it we're moving on but I don't uh no I
don't think so
thanks to Peggy for the Super Chat do
you think Oz's drinkable silver could
alleviate Trump's swollen eyes it's
possible yeah
regarding student loan forgiveness can't
we condition the Forgiveness amount to
some service-based program like
Community volunteering sure you you
could do any number of things
and thanks Peggy for another Super Chat
very much appreciate that thank you
let's listen in a little bit uh 7 40. uh
talk about a spiritual awakening Mike
Lindell has talked about this so much
and what this is his passion for this
country is not only to save this country
but to lead people to Christ and to
leave people to the recovery the Lindo
recovery recovery that we want to
encourage everybody right now to go to
mypillow.com
mystore.com is a two great websites that
not only support uh Mike Lindell but
also supports us as well gives it
enables you to buy some quality products
uh not only at a discounted price
because when you put that promo code or
span you'll get a special discount on
that also there's a buy one get one who
doesn't love a buy one get one I love it
buy one guess I love it I don't care if
it's uh Big Macs I'm getting a buy one
get one even something as crappy as a
Big Mac I guess he's saying he's still
he'll take it uh wow what a grift what a
grift a lot happening oh my God look at
this bed sheet set Giza Elegance my
pillow roll and go anywhere my pillow
the six piece towel set
uh wow wow wow
I'm going to be in recovery just from
having all that product in my house that
is really something else
other super chats coming in WoW Peggy is
dumping in ten dollar super chats I
really appreciate that Peggy
drinkable silver yeah that's something
else that's something else let's see if
we can find one more voicemail
um
oh boy
hey David packman my name is Jay Yang
um this is Troy York I just I just am so
bored by Troy it's it's hard to find a
more pedantic caller than Troy you guys
want to hear one more call from Juan the
troll man
just because his last one was so
interesting should we listen to one more
I'm curious
oops I thought this the phone number is
almost the same as the troll man but
it's not okay let's listen
um my name is ginger and I live in Ron
the Nazi territory and I was wondering
if you had read
um the article put out by CNN about the
cops and agencies being able to track
people who were searching for abortion
information or no every PNC pill they're
talking about
getting that information in order to
prosecute people just thought that that
was very
um
putinish and I'm wondering if you had
any
news on that I don't I don't and The
Voice to Text translated putin-ish as
poop mesh which is a weird
weird translation
that is something else huh
okay
so that happened and that's uh that's a
whole thing super chat's coming in evil
vacuum says David sir loved the show
it's like a lighthouse of logic on the
foggy Shoreline of Madness mute
beautiful imagery that is some really
nice imagery there
well done truly well done I want to say
thank you to Donald Richards who just
signed up on my website joinpakman.com
and David cousler who also just signed
up on my website putting us at 31.31
Kyle says David sir wanted to thank you
for your Stellar performance via Cameo
I'm sorry Cameo for what was a very
early Father's Day gift for my wife much
appreciated yeah I opted into a Mother's
Day discount on Cameo and got a ton of
early Father's Day gift
like uh requests
which is which is interesting do we
think Trump will bail because it's
raining because he really doesn't go out
in the rain cause RSV to 998899
information will be on the screen as
well American Heart for gold
mypillow.com we are live from Greensburg
Pennsylvania on a rainy Friday night
where you're glad you're joining us a
president is scheduled to take the stage
here shortly it's it's the former
president
hello I'm Mike bindel inventor of my
pillow thanks to your support you've
helped make my pillow become one of the
fastest growing companies and we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines made thousands of jobs right
here in the USA why is pants solo did
you guys see that
that was weird his pants were like very
very low and I wake up more well rested
in the morning that's why I invented my
pillow my patented fill adjustments it's
interesting to call it an invention you
know that that's actually that's kind of
interesting anyway uh okay let's
continue it looks like we are getting
very very close to Donald Trump speaking
and this is a rally to endorse Dr Oz and
it is expected that the crowd might boo
Dr Oz
so that's something to keep in mind they
do not seem to be taking to Dr Mehmet Oz
and we'll see the expectation is that
there's going to be a big uh big big boo
session
um wow super chats are just dumping in
David sir oh no this one I read
this man should go to the maintenance
court so he can see women taking fathers
to court
because the father refuses to pay
maintenance oh I guess that must be what
they call child support in South Africa
how can a woman Force the father to take
responsibility for the child
right
David can you clip yourself saying
cheese butter and use it as a reaction
audio for anything positive I really
enjoy the way you say cheese butter
thank you
is there a BOGO situation going on at
McDonald's right now I'm hungry love the
show what if the woman doesn't want the
child and the man does what does BOGO
mean
anybody know what BOGO is I have no I
hope that's not racist
anybody know
huge night for Trump back Texas
candidates back in March oh buy one get
one buy one get one okay okay got it
oh my God look it's the it's the the
Pawn Stars guy everyone and welcome back
to right side broadcast
would you say rsbn is the channel with
the where the people who talk have the
worst diction
and pronunciation
of anyone I think it is I think it's
even worse than oan were they like
visibly it's like there's a lot of
mush-mouthed stuff see you in just a
second what that did in Ohio and where
we brought Alex and I want to talk about
do we think it's going to have the
possibly the same effect here in
Pennsylvania but before we do that
Alex tell us about Ohio what did you
notice well what I noticed in Ohio is JD
Vance a guy who had a couple of comments
that he had said about President Trump
that we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel
yeah okay anyway
uh the super chats are coming in so fast
I can barely keep up with them he's
former failed presidential candidate
Donald J Trump right if Dr Oz is booed
in a few minutes it will be seen as a
humiliation for Trump as another of his
endorsements will have flopped let's
hope Trump does not like to go out in
the rain because the rain ruins his hair
remember how he dropped the umbrella
because the wind was blowing at his hair
yeah
what are your views about how Dinesh
D'Souza went from being a semi-respected
debate interlocutor with the likes of
Hitchens to being a Maga Advocate I'd
never remember
D'Souza being considered equivalent to
Hitchens I just don't have a
recollection of that I apologize I can't
comment because I don't know that I
agree with the premise
anybody remembered D'Souza being seen
like a Hitchens type figure
I don't know them
Dr Oz spoke earlier and was not booed
there was actually some booing
but uh we're gonna see we're gonna see
what happens if you're just joining us
we are moments away from the rally
moments away Trump's scheduled to speak
in 10 minutes I do want to ask everybody
for a favor
as many of you may know
uh we are a program that really depends
on your support and I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on the on this I'm
just going to mention I would love for
you to sign up on my website you know we
have all these different platforms where
people can support us and they all they
take they take they take they take they
take they take they they just take
slices 10 20 30 40 percent we have a
membership program on our website we
just pay 2.9 percent to swipe credit
cards virtually
and all the other money stays in-house
we've lost other means of support on a
whim the YouTube algorithm will
demonetize us the Facebook algorithm
will say we're doing anti-vax which of
course we're not twitch will ban us for
showing an image during a trial which I
won't even mention uh but our membership
program is what works so I would love
for you to sign up at joinpakman.com we
have this coupon code Obama Obama you
have to spell it correctly
incorrectly right you know your
o-b-a-m-n-a you will get a discount I
will shout you out and thank you the bar
will fill up hopefully to 100. and if
you already have a membership there's
now a feature on our website where you
can give one away we right now have
666. oh that's ominous there are 666
people waiting for free memberships
right now so be aware that they will not
go to waste they will not go to waste
you can also buy a pillow you could go
to my pillow but I suggest do the thing
on our website it's a beautiful thing
and everybody will get a thank you for
example Amber Fritz gifting one and
Kevin gouldi gifting one those are
numbers 32 and 33. those go to Sebastian
mix and Claire Gilmore now we only have
664 waiting
which is still a hell of a number of
satanic memberships coming in here yeah
David sir do you ever reference the add
font test media bias chart
we looked at my position on it and we
found it totally arbitrary and not
really accurate but it made for an
entertaining five minutes on the Stream
make of it what you will
trying again to say thank you to
whomever bought a subscription to the
David Pacman show as I surely appreciate
it yeah it's a great thing because
people will ask for a free membership
and a few days will go by and all of a
sudden they get an email and it says sir
you've been given a free membership
and people just love it people love it
David based on your own political views
who do you think is the least insane
option from the Republicans in
Pennsylvania Bartos I think Bartos he's
the one who we jokingly called the
boring guy during the debate I think
Bartos is the best choice if it has
fetterman's the best choice but he's a
Democrat from the five Republicans I
think Bartos is the best choice if you
said if it's going to be one of them
I would say it's Bartos
I have to go to work at 3am sorry David
I can't watch this until tomorrow well
apology accepted Peggy
and very much appreciate your support
very very much
I want to say thanks to Alpha Omega for
signing up on my website and Jackson
godzi numbers 34 and 35. also Brian
wrestler gifting one that's number 36
and that one we're giving away to
Anthony
miramontes is there a mosh pit going on
here I think Dr Oz is from Western PA
I'm not sure which district he's in for
sure but Western PA is a more
conservative area especially more so
than the East oh boy
I want to say thanks to David dinar who
just gifted a membership that's number
37 the recipient there is political
Peroni
um okay political Peroni is the
recipient there
uh also thanks to Evan Krieger for
getting a membership for himself at
joinpakman.com
uh what other coupon codes are there I
mean you could use the coupon code sad
Trump but I think Obama's the funniest
code Obama by far
like not even not even close
people want one more voicemail all right
let me see if I can find a good one for
you
hey David I can't tell if it's just me
or is that like 50 000 people in the
crowd I think it's record-breaking oh
this I've I don't think there's ever
been a crowd like this The Beatles never
had a crowd like this
not even close
this is this is just it's an incredible
crowd and it's electric as well
it's an absolutely electric crowd David
sir have you seen James Austin Johnson's
Trump impression on Saturday night is
that the new guy I I think I have seen
it let's search for it
foreign
if that's the new guy it's very good
is this the guy
[Music]
yeah yeah that guy's really good let me
see if I can find one uh James Austin
Johnson Trump one with better audio he's
really really good
man I'm having trouble actually finding
one now though
oh wait is it here
oh yeah here it is
[Music]
Mr President you've never actually
campaigned with Glenn young and did you
well no I I never did Glenn Glenn
don't you dare
you need to hear this you know I was
never there there with Glenn you know
there there I was never there there
wow okay so it's mostly a music segment
but we we at least you get the
impression that guy's very very good
he's actually he does the weird throat
thing yeah exactly no he's excellent
he's excellent uh okay memberships are
dumping in like I've maybe never seen
before thanks to James biard and
Michelle and David DeCamp
numbers
39 and 40.
also want to say thanks to these are
gifters now Eddie Padilla
oh man Brian wrestler
we're about to give some gifts another
one from David dinar
Joe Rader sending a gift
Emma Jean Miller that's five gifts puts
us at 45 the recipients are
let's see here
things are moving pretty quickly here
Flora Garcia Joseph Tate Marissa Raider
wait hold on Joe Rader gifted one and
and Marissa Raider got one I wonder if
they're related that'd be weird Theo van
Rossum
who asked for two memberships so you get
none sorry Theo you can't request him
double
and Sal martini
very much appreciate that
uh oh my God these are these are
happening Jan euroda
signed up Monique Townsend
Dan Everson
those are 46 47 and 48 apologies guys
I'm trying to keep up with what's going
on here Brian wrestler gifting another
one Kimberly Nitza with a gift key our
friend Kyoko from Japan gifting another
one and Timothy O'Hearn with another
gift that's 52.
and the next people are Cindy Lowe gets
a free membership Thomas Curry gets a
free one free one esche hummingbird and
Dena motto All getting free memberships
this this is wild
yeah I think the website's gonna crash
there's too many people signing up too
many people
uh
everybody okay since sensing a weird
energy in the chat today
hope we don't have to start Mass Banning
people
that would be weird
yes you you Dr Oz spoke already but
Trump is about to speak and then he will
presumably bring up Oz and the rumor is
people are going to boo
that's the that that's the rumor
we'll see
hi David I don't
I don't uh season one episode one of The
Apprentice last night out of sheer
curiosity uh the legality of the stream
is in question but you know it was the
uh it was the best stream uh best stream
ever so that's not really a problem the
issue though is
uh I feel like Donald Trump has never
actually learned anything in his life I
feel like one day he I feel he was just
born with everything he would ever know
and he already knew everything every
word you would ever say and has never
picked up anything new his entire life I
just find it odd
okay
hey what up David B Dog here I got
another question for you dog
um do you think uh Oprah would vote for
doctor as dog or do you think she would
vote for the Democratic candidate I
honestly I even though Oprah's
responsible for unleashing Dr Oz on the
media landscape I don't think she would
vote for him this dog because I know
Oprah has a close relationship with the
fact that I can't imagine
I'll say about that dog dog I'm uh I
don't know if you can hear that dog but
I know it sounds like there was a dog in
the background actually
um
okay oh wow I there are more people
signing there's more gifts coming in
let's give away some more gifts Greg
Tullis just bought a gifted membership
Kyoko got another gifted membership
Marco Janet just got a gifted membership
Kyoko got another one
guys if our Japanese viewers are
disengaged please Stanley minarik just
sent a gift David dinar sent another one
Lisa Rader wow everybody's Raider so
that's um six gifts that's 58 the
recipients are Maribel
Peter Kelly
Frank Bonilla Jeremy Reinhold Anthony
Vicario and Andrea tanevsky I'll I'll
give them away all night
David sir The only voice of Sanity I
dare listen to says Mark Fillion
appreciate you mark always great to see
you in the chat
and then some selfish people signing up
for themselves Richard Bryan getting
himself a membership on my website
next is Peter divincenzo
Christopher Johnson signing up
those are numbers 59 60 and 61. guys I
can't tell you how much I appreciate the
support it's been uh it's been slow
lately because we're in this lull before
the election and after the last one and
it's it's fantastic to see so many
people engaged Bonnie madazak with a
gift
Patricia Goss gifts one also Leon Scott
Kennedy with a gift those are numbers 62
63 and 64 and I'm glad to give those
away to Rossi Rivera
comb
and Brent Beitel
everybody gets a free membership in
order okay if you want a free one you go
to davidpackman.com free membership
there's only 643 people ahead of you in
line
it's it's what it is guys I I don't know
what to tell you it's what it is David
considering it's raining in Pennsylvania
do you think Trump will bring up showers
and how it ruins his hair in big ocean
water oh
guaranteed Trump talks about the weather
it's I I wouldn't even I think if we did
an over under it's five does Trump talk
about the weather more or fewer than
five times
thanks to play and joy for gifting 10
Subs on Twitch what a beautiful gift
there
everybody's saying he's going to mention
the weather more than five times maybe
he will
David sir what do you think is the
single most important thing the
Democrats need to get done before the
midterms to positively impact it to
remind everybody
that the reason Roe v Wade is being
overturned is Trump beat Hillary
and that should be a reminder of the
consequences of these damn elections
I I don't know how else to say it
it's just
it is something
hey David who's your favorite President
I don't have one
how do you think Joe Biden will be
remembered in history too soon to say
he's been in office 15 months appreciate
the Super Chat Lana but we need time
we need time for those questions to
quote garyvee you got time you got time
shot game take a shot whenever Trump
says in the history of America yeah I
don't want anybody ending up in the
emergency room today so please don't do
that
please don't do that
yeah it's kind of like who what's your
favorite book it's like I don't know I
read four books in the last month it's
hard to say my favorite of all time
obviously it's
Ready Player One
that's a that's a joke I've actually not
even read Ready Player One
thanks to Andrew AVR drums for gifting a
subscription that's number 75. I'm glad
to give that subscription to Andrew
krivetsky
also want to say thanks to Robert
nunenkamp who just signed up for himself
and is number 76. guys we haven't hit
100 memberships during a stream in a
long time
and we may be able to do it trollman
Quan even after I suggested he's an
in-cell has just gifted another
membership that's number 77 and that one
goes to Neil Shaw
Nathan says David sir do you still speak
to Louis I randomly saw him on a craft
beer video LOL I did I actually texted
with Lewis today his band is playing a
show tonight
I don't know where but they should have
our stream on in the background
shimanetta a boring world where the
concept of dirty jokes doesn't exist a
future that could be ours in America
I don't even know what that's about
Jorgen lundkvist says keep up the good
work thank you uh Jorgen
I appreciate that very very much
and thanks to Cortina GT for the twitch
Prime subscription
let's listen to what's happening here
about how nice Liz was so
it's like a mosh pit and paying him
well we
well we haven't seen
it yet since probably Dallas Alex is
behind the scenes like you're constantly
writing articles how can people find
your articles and other rsbn articles
you can go tell us about your writing
realistically or seeing inter
see when does this recession hit while
the White House sits there and boasts
about how great their economy is uh how
easy is it to pick apart for the average
American when you look at all this well
I think the average amount man this
commentary couldn't possibly be anymore
uh
meaningless
Gamers is my predictions for this rally
sir sir glitch glitch glitch incoherent
rambling finishing with awkward dancing
with that terrible country song no no no
the terrible country song is at the
beginning and then at the end it's YMCA
you've got the order wrong
it's going to be a different sort of
situation
the all of those components will be
there
I've never seen a kind of like Music
Festival
kind of dance scene at any of these
events
kind of an interesting thing
we'll see we'll see what Trump brings
I'm telling you guys Trump hates being
out in the rain I don't know maybe it'll
be the shortest rally ever I looked at
the weather and it actually seems like
it's going to get worse as they wait so
I don't know that waiting
is going to do much for him I really
don't
I want to say thank you to Alex Delaney
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code Obama Obama and his new
member number 79 today 79 I encourage
you in all seriousness our goal is to do
all we're we're trying to cover all the
2022 debates the Trump endorsement
rallies we've been doing Republican
debates Democratic debates we've been
doing some of the Johnny Hurt Johnny
Hurt Johnny Depp Amber Heard trial all
of it our goal is to continue and the
best way to support the work we do is to
do what a lot of these 79 people have
done which is sign up on my website
great people
just Inc these are these are great
Americans many of them aren't even
American to be perfectly Frank I don't
care where you're from
do you think Trump's sitting in a tent
behind the stage waiting for people to
show up I don't know if Trump arrives
and goes right out on stage or whether
he does the thing where he kind of hangs
out as the crowd builds
um super chat a lot of the commentary
from the online left in regard to Roe v
Wade has been horrible they're still
playing the both sides meme about
Democrats not doing enough kolinsky and
tyt to name a few garbage haven't seen
it don't watch any shows like mine I'm
just going to keep doing my commentary
which is we mostly blame the people who
voted for Trump trump for picking these
justices the justices for doing this
and we also are aware that if a few more
democratic voters had come out to vote
for Hillary Roe v Wade wouldn't be
overturned it's just a mathematical
reality we it's okay guys we're we're
all we're all friends here
we don't have to attack anybody it's
just it's just what it is
will you ever interview or have a
discussion with Brian Tyler Cohen would
love to see it anytime
would love to
thanks to Joanne Dodge for signing up on
my website Joanne is new member number
80. okay now
what percentage of the way are we to a
hundred the goal is a hundred and we're
at 80. let me see if I can do this in my
head eight divided by 10 is 0.8
carry nothing 0 divided by zero is zero
so it's 0.80 and then to go from a
decimal to a percentage you multiply by
a hundred meaning we are eighty percent
of the way there is that right is that
correct
so it's only seventy percent damn hold
on
did I do something wrong 80 divided by a
hundred
I guess it's 70 yeah I don't know
I'm perplexed by that by the numbers
Austin muckenthaler just gifted a
membership and so did Hector Santiago
thanks guys that puts us at 82 and the
recipients are Shannon Hallman and
Michael Lovejoy getting free memberships
wow
that is something else
lucky people I'm telling you very very
lucky people
David I'm loving the soaking wet crowd
on display on the stream right now I
wanted to ask you maybe a hard question
to answer or even begin to answer how
would you go about correcting somebody's
perception who credulously believes that
Tim Poole is a Centrist and that Jimmy
Dore is an authentic Lefty I would be
interested in knowing your approach I
think it really depends on how
weaponized the person's delusions are
but I think what I would start with with
someone like Tim Poole I would go okay
um
how do you define that someone is on the
left
first
and then I would say or Centrist or
whatever and then I would say what
positions
does whoever hold that you believe are
under that umbrella I think that would
be my Approach and just let them answer
you know
um Bryson says he can't do the
calculation because Florida got rid of
the math books that's fair Bay photo
says superb maths or skills math skills
sir your textbooks must not have been
banned that's right
David sir being from Northwestern
Pennsylvania I can attest that outside
the city's Trump cult is in full effect
even Pennsylvania is pretty rural
despite the few big cities this besides
I know that yeah you could almost call
us pencil Tucky keep up the good work go
fetterman well said
gamer Batman says I'm his left wing as
any person could be but I occasionally
and I mean really occasionally watch
news does that make me a bad person no I
don't even know what that what you're
talking about
my eight-week-old daughter and I are
watching together sanity and solidarity
from the UK what's your favorite drum
rudiment oh I'm a fan of the double
paradiddle because you can trans you can
you can put it you can play it in four
four
uh or you can move it over to twelve
eight or six eight
and you can also use accents where you
can play it in 12 8 but accent every
fourth or play it in four four and
accent every sixth extremely versatile
rudiment extremely versatile
hard to beat really
that's what they tell me
it is a future where the government is
so fed up with inappropriate things in
media such as porn and sex ed that they
outlaw it and make sure no one talks or
jokes about it and we're all forced to
wear monitors to keep us in line sounds
bad
David just wanted to let you know love
your membership content highly encourage
members to Deep dive into your members
site and take full advantage of the
membership
thank you
thank you thank you thank you let me
thank a few people who have signed up
Jonathan Ferguson has gotten a new
membership and Dr Annabelle Evans has
signed up that puts us at 84.
also a gift coming in from Marco Janet
that is number 85 and that gift goes to
Eve Tobin Eve you will hear from us in
the next couple days with how to claim
that membership lastly thanks to Susana
floor for gifting a subscription over on
Twitch
thank you very much everybody
uh will we get to a hundred today I I
have no idea
that's up to you guys
let's start a band
oh I I guess there's a lot of trolls in
the chat I haven't been paying attention
thanks Palisade and Sarah is cool
putting us at 88
uh there there do seem to be a lot of
trolls on the chat
yeah
people you can yes moderators can start
Banning if necessary if they violate the
rules yep
dance the most I've ever seen him dance
and and maybe we need to put a trump
dance cam a clock on him because I think
he danced for a full minute total uh why
are these people standing in the dark
bring a light with you please please
bring a light
I meant to say I occasionally watch
Newsmax does that make me a bad person
no I mean I watch it too just to like
learn what's going on
I don't think that's a big deal I'm not
watching it for I think the question is
are you watching Newsmax 4 news that
would be a concern if you're watching
Newsmax out of sort of a curiosity
that's fine Cynthia is emailing saying
how do I gift the membership okay a
Cynthia it's really really easy
since you're already a member okay when
you go through the sign up process
you check this box where it says is this
a gift
you check it see that
you check the box and then it'll be a
gift and then you can type in if you
want you can use the coupon code Obama
and then look at that
Obama that's something huh
super easy we make it really easy you
don't even have to pick someone to gift
it to I handle the gifting
okay so let's see
we're at 88 out of 100.
I think that means we're like 90 roughly
90 of the way there right I mean
seems like it
you think that's a future Republicans
would like to do
um
I I have to think about it no what not
really no
I don't think so
I don't think so
if you're just joining us we are
effortlessly waiting for Donald Trump
now 15 minutes late it's raining
and uh Trump hates the rain
but presumably he's going to come out
and speak soon I think
dark Pepsi asks David sir will you be
watching the mayoral lace race in La I
really don't want billionaire Caruso to
be the next mayor of LA and LA County I
don't know what's going on in the in the
Los Angeles mayoral race I know Eric
Garcetti he's a fellow Hispanic Jew like
me
Los Angeles mayoral race
2022 let's see who's running
okay uh it's oh it's in November
Garcetti is ineligible due to term
limits
yeah I don't know what I'm gonna have to
learn about what's going on I don't know
I couldn't possibly say a word about
that race I just don't have a clue
what's going on there
I interviewed Garcetti about a year ago
I guess and
don't know anything about what's been
going on there since
okay thank you post happy
a lot Happening Here more gifts are
coming in Marcos villoria has just
gifted a subscription Austin
muckenthaler has gifted another one
James biard has gifted another one and
Elizabeth Stauffer has just gifted we
are at 92 four more gifted memberships
are going out Nick Parker gets the first
one David roast gets the second one
Laura shulk gets the third and Steph
McGarry gets the fourth looks like
they're now into YMCA showing up you
know Beth I can't but there's thousands
in thousands of people here which it
seems like like a thousand people it's
very sparse
Progressive prepper says I've lived in
Pennsylvania all my life 63 years
believe me pencil Tucky is real go
fetterman yes
go fetterman
I think that's an important message
today
very very important
what do we think is a realistic estimate
of this crowd I mean this is like the
whole crowd they're showing you
everything I know it looks kind of full
but this is this is it
um
is it a thousand people
something like that 800 someone says
plus uh I was talking to him I was he
was getting out of his car and he said
look hey I want to say I was in
Pennsylvania that night right when it
was cold and rainy again and you know
what a lot of people tell us that it's
very it's a moment in history for these
people that they get to see all this
going on hey we're a few minutes away
please share this broadcast like comment
tell us where you're watching it from
put it in the comments say hey I'm
watching from the UK we get a lot of
people that watch this from the UK by
the way that's actually a good idea can
you guys let me know in the comments
where you're watching from because it
seems as though a ton of the audience is
in Pennsylvania
from the number of people that are
commenting
oh wow we have people from all over the
world Vietnam Australia Finland
anytime anyone says they're from Finland
I imagine they're watching my streams
while eating that great salmon soup they
have in Finland
a lot of Austin and New York City people
Massachusetts Switzerland wow it's the
middle of the night in Switzerland
Thailand and the nambia Beautiful
Canadians checking in
Max silco oh that's cool
mini Annapolis someone's watching from
Nars let me see do I have my Nars
message
uh Nars is so good I don't know that I
have it though
oh that's really too bad
I've got to add Nars to my thing now
um New Zealand that's great
I would really be interested in visiting
New Zealand
malvania now that that's that I've not
heard of minamar
I'm proud of Newsmax for spelling
Pennsylvania correctly I know
we need a statute which would have
forced a vote on Merrick Garland's
nomination that I agree with
that I agree with let's give away some
more membership Nicholas stratz just
gifted One Rebecca Coles just gifted one
Amber Fritz sends a gift
Megan Balano sends a gift
Michael Francis sends a gift that's five
Joe wit Dusky withaxky sends a gift and
that's number six Michael Blaylock sends
a gift that's number seven
Tiffany mclay sends a gift and that's
number eight I think I'm about to give
away eight here that puts us at 100 the
following eight people get a free
membership Nico Leo
Melinda Bly
Carrie Casa Jamie Burns Sarah Louise
Chris bellows
CVS abuses that's weird
Evelyn Barney
congratulations you get a free
membership also thanks to Katie McCall
taratoa
and Tom Walker who have gotten
themselves memberships nothing wrong
with that
fine to get one for yourself puts a set
102.
and lastly one more gift from Juan troll
man Peralta putting us at 103 and that
one goes to Wesley Taylor lastly guys
I'm not ignoring twitch of course people
with Bezos bucks get a thank you minty
just gifted five on Twitch
rlm and Richburg Nation also chiming in
that's seven 103 plus 7 is a hundred and
ten As Trump enters
Peggy says I need to sleep working at
3am but I know this will be like
watching a train wreck
hope I won't regret check out Michigan
gardener on YouTube and try his Trifecta
I watch Michigan Gardener I prefer uh
epic gardening who's a buddy of mine but
Michigan Gardener is good too I'm from
Kentucky not all of us are Trump or
Hillbillies P.S Rand Paul sucks
beautiful message
David as a Samsung user do you have
thoughts on the terrorism that is
iMessage
uh yeah it's uh it's very bad
David sir I left a comment on
trigonometry's video you should show off
some of the good ones if anyone hasn't
seen them they're hilarious maybe we
will do that after yeah
thanks to Heigl
for the twitch Prime subscription you
are number 111 Trump looking extra
extra let's just put it that way welcome
to Michael Francis who's a new member
Leslie short is a new member Joseph
Jaworski is a new member that's 114.
we got another gift from Marco Janet
that's number 115 and that one goes to
Frank Pinero
another gift from Andrew Culp thanks
Andrew that's number 116.
recipient there is Gladys Amato
we'll keep toweling them during Trump's
speech don't worry about it this is a
very strange look for Trump I guess
because it's raining he's wearing kind
of this uh Blackberry I call it a
Blackberry it's a little bit like have
you guys ever seen um
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory is
that is that a film people in the
audience are familiar with
anyway I won't say more but if people
have seen Charlie in the Chocolate
Factory and you remember the blueberry
kid okay
what weather
so this is the first mention of the
weather we're gonna have a lot of fun
Pennsylvania we're gonna have a lot of
fun
they said sir the weather's so bad we
could do it another night I said do you
tell that to Pennsylvania because I'm
not going to this is great it's great to
be back in this beautiful Commonwealth
with thousands of proud hard-working
American Patriots and six months from
now the people of Pennsylvania are going
to vote to fire the radical left
Democrats
and you're going to send Dr Oz to fight
for you in the U.S Senate
and you're going to elect an incredible
were some people yelling no the first
Republicans to Congress together we are
going to end crazy Nancy Pelosi she's
crazy
it end her career
they say she wants to move to Florida
keep her the hell out of Florida
keep her where she is earlier this week
our movement had a series of Blockbuster
victories in Ohio and Indiana you know
that right
we nominated an amazing group of Mega
Patriots to fight for us in November
including the future U.S senator you
know that is JD Vance where the hell is
JD where's JD what a guy he well he's
we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel who
are Riding High he's gonna have a great
future and we're going to have a great
future with another person that we
happen to be here for
in fact every single candidate that I
endorsed won their primers on Tuesday
they went 22-0 and in Texas a couple of
weeks before we won 33-0
so we have a total record of 55-0
remember Trump's actual record on
endorsements in general elections is
very mediocre that takes place actually
in uh in Ohio a man named J.R Majewski
do you know J.R I interviewed him
so Jr was sort of a candidate but I
think he was sort of just this guy is
soaking wet huh so fun and we had a
tremendous crowd for
all of the incredible Patriots of Ohio
and we had just an amazing crowd I said
where's J.R Majewski is he around here
and you can see his head way to hell in
the back
and what he is he's a farmer he's a
great farmer and he'd carved Trump into
the cornfield or whatever field wheat
toward whatever the hell he had and he'd
carved
in massive massive letters trumpet you
could see it from 30 000. you can check
out my interview with the guy he's
talking about J.R Majewski pulled him
out I said J.R I want to thank you now I
didn't want to endorse him because he
wasn't really going to win but I called
him out and we had lots of people we had
lots of people there and guess what
happened now he was running against very
good professional politicians J.R
Majewski won for Congress can you
believe this it's a nominee
and it'll be great but we didn't expect
that so maybe we can say a set of fish I
interviewed the guy he's not he's not a
great candidate but he's great and we
have a lot of fun and we have a country
that's in big trouble Tuesday's primary
results sir isn't it fun that the
country's in a lot of trouble I've
transformed the face of the Republican
party thank goodness we are now the
working people's party but we're really
the party of everyone we're the party
you know what we're the party of common
sense I think more than anything else
hey Zach
we believe in putting America First and
we're going to keep on fighting to make
America great again
all right
and you know sadly we have a new theme
too it's called save America because our
country has to be saved
these people are destroying our country
they're destroying our country
so we want to save America too it's a
sad that's a sad statement to make who
would have thought we would have had to
make we never did so good as we were
doing a year and a half ago but we have
to save America save our country you
could take the five worst Presidents in
American history and put them together
and they wouldn't and I'm still worse
damage that Joe Biden has done to our
country in just 16 months
[Applause]
foreign
the contrast between the Trump
administration's amazing success and Joe
Biden's breathtaking failure there's
never been anything nobody's ever seen
anything like this even the fake news is
saying it little bit now as bad as they
are and as fake as they are they could
not be more Stark and let's look at what
are you talking about
I got gas way down I got
1.87 cents a gallon
and they have it if you can get it
at five dollars six dollars seven
dollars even eight dollars last week a
gallon
and you know when you talk about
inflation that's a big factor right
there a lot of the inflation that you
see is because of what we did we were
energy independent a year and a half ago
who would believe it we didn't need
anybody
now we go into uh places like Venezuela
we're back with OPEC we're accepting oil
from Iran even though they say they're
not they are
with the help of Pennsylvania energy
workers we achieved American Energy
Independence and you remember I said
they are going to kill you on energy
Pennsylvania is a big energy State
they've destroyed it Biden surrendered
our energy dominance and
he goes begging to OPEC you know you
didn't hear the word a lot of you
noticing that this guy looks like JD
Vance it's not JD Vance but I see the
resemblance the guy's soaking wet
already he would have you would have
never thought you even had to do
business with we created the safest
Border in the history of the United
States
we ended Catch and Release we deported
record numbers of illegal alien gang
members like MS-13
MS-13 you know what they do they use
knives because they're more painful they
cut young women up they cut them up into
pieces did he say thirteen we built
hundreds of miles of border wall in fact
we completely finished our original plan
we then added much more border wall and
almost got that finished too three weeks
more would have been finished and then
we had the rigged election okay
the border wall was a great success and
gave us record low illegal immigration
without even building it at work that's
crazy turned it into the worst ever we
had the best border we've ever had in
the history of our country recorded
and now we have the worst border we've
ever had and all you have to do is look
at it and you know the fake news hardly
covers it
yeah you can turn on to ABC CBS
NBC watch deface the nation ladies and
gentlemen it's Donald Trump on deface
the nation
you can watch uh NBC fake news
sleepy eyes Chuck Todd they don't talk
about it they don't show what's going on
they're poisoning our country I rebuilt
our military including our nuclear
capability and the creation of space
force 75 years since Air Force
and they decided to give 85 just because
it's been a while since you created a
new
a wing doesn't mean we needed to and
including seven hundred thousand machine
guns rifles and Firearms of all types as
well as brand new airplanes helicopters
tanks and listen to this 70
000 trucks you know there's not a used
car lot dealer that would have probably
500 670 000 and many of them are armor
plated and the most expensive you can
buy is
seventy thousand trucks think of that I
was getting a safely out of Afghanistan
I'm the one that got it down to two
thousand we were going to keep Bagram
because of China one hour away from
where China makes its nuclear weapons we
want to keep Bagram we gave it away you
know who's occupying Bagram right now
China
hmm
creating peace in the Middle East ending
the endless Wars and bringing our troops
to Hell back home it's time 21 years
China hadn't turned Afghanistan into the
great just humiliation in American
history I believe that too with soldiers
killed and horrifically that's Trump's
classic move where he reads the
teleprompter and then reacts to it
you're supposed to pretend those are
your words it's been the biggest
embarrassment I believe that too yeah
just that were left behind many of them
Putin saw this incredible weakness and
that's when he decided to invade Ukraine
he didn't look at Ukraine when I was
there he would never have done it would
have never ever happened 100 and now you
look at the death and the destruction
this is the most dangerous time in the
history of our country because of the
magical power of modern day weaponry
they don't know how to deal with
Vladimir Putin they don't they're saying
exactly the wrong thing at the wrong
time
they know nothing about psychology Trump
said what Putin was doing was smart that
doesn't sound like the right time to say
that millions of people will end up
being killed
because we don't know what the hell
we're doing
they are saying exactly the wrong thing
at the wrong time
this should never have happened and
frankly it should not be allowed to
continue should not be allowed to
continue what's going on in Ukraine
should not be allowed to continue there
was no reason for that to happen
and I'm telling you he watched
Afghanistan and he saw what happened the
way we pulled out where we took our
military out first whoever heard how
stupid could you be do you know when I
was there I spoke to the leader of the
Taliban Abdul oh boy and I said here we
go no more you're not going to kill any
of us sir they were killing a lot of
soldiers under Obama snipers and
everything else you're not going to do
it Abdul I said it much stuff I don't
want to sort of imitate it now but I
said Abdul
if you do anything more we're going to
blow you to pieces we're going to blow
you to pieces I showed him a picture of
his house
that's your Excellency I understand you
call me your Excellency which was nice
I wonder if he calls Biden your
Excellency actually
no Biden wouldn't speak to him we're so
angry at what are you talking about he's
so angry at them
and the gross incompetence the only
thing they're good at is rigging
elections it's the only thing they do
well it's the only thing they know how
to do
but we have the wrong people in the
wrong place at the wrong time that's
what we have under my leadership America
was strong and America was respected
like never before and not all of the
foreign leaders loved me why would they
I said you have to pay for NATO you have
to take our Goods the trade deals were
no good I redid trade deals and made
them great remember that usmca was
almost identical to NAFTA with some very
minor changes which was a disaster we
made the usmca which is great and Mexico
and Canada now want to renegotiate the
deal and so the United States says oh
well we'll love to meet with you anytime
and they will do that and yet we got
screwed for many many decades with that
horrible deal that we had to live with
nobody said let's renegotiate it but we
renegotiated we got a great deal usmca
now leaders of countries don't all these
you think all these people nodding right
now about usmca this guy this woman
everybody's nodding do you think if you
go up to them and you go what do you
think is the biggest Improvement that
usmca made over NAFTA do you think any
of them could list one thing which is
what's happened
because we've been ripped off by
everybody both on trade with military
with NATO
just a disaster not a single one you
know in NATO I got them to pay hundreds
of billions of dollars they weren't
paying their bills I said you're
delinquent they said well it went
delinquent sir will you defend us should
Russia attack I said no if you're
delinquent I'm not the fit I don't know
if you can tell there's like a little
girl right here you can only see like
the top of her head that they're
bringing kids to these things
we had the greatest economy in the
history of the world with virtually no
inflation we had no inflation
we had energy we had cheap gasoline we
had cheap electricity where everything
was so good all they had to do is go to
the beach and relax
the best borders
Biden created the worst inflation in
more than 50 years and it's going to go
much higher
it's costing families more than six
thousand dollars a year that's so Biden
didn't create it and it's probably not
going to go much higher I expect
inflation will start to come down within
two to three months largest tax increase
in history I gave you the largest tax
cut in the history of our country larger
than the tax cut given by Ronald Reagan
and gave you the largest regulation Cuts
in American history that's why we had so
many jobs and you know when you hear
about their low
when you hear about their low
unemployment numbers
they're terrible numbers because we had
164 million people working this is a
classic Republican move when the
unemployment rate is low under them they
brag about it Biden comes in the
unemployment rate is even lower and he
goes well now we're going to talk about
the labor participation right it's it
they've been doing this for as long as
I've been doing the show most of you
probably already know the game
we came up with a lot of great ones
crooked Hillary crooked how crooked is
Hillary Clinton
[Music]
Obama
this is a group that's very strongly for
Law and Order the Constitution and due
process demanding the imprisonment of a
woman who never mind convicted she
hasn't even been charged with a crime
law firms I guess or somebody I don't
know they got into various people that
were having to do with the Russia hoax
and they have emails like I can't
believe this is going on they're
believing this stuff about Russia Russia
Russia let's keep it going as long as we
can it was set up as a way of explaining
a fake it was a fake con job you know
con job was a con job they set it up as
a way of explaining why she lost and we
lost I'll tell you what
we made her lose you know why we had
huge crowds she didn't have credits
anyway it was an explanation for why she
lost it was Russia Russia everyone said
that's strange you know during the
campaign people would come out to me and
they'd say so do you know anything about
Russia no what do you ask no I don't
blame it I can tell you about Russia but
why do you know I don't know sir just I
hear about Russia sure there's another
one would come up and they'd say uh sir
sure you've had anything to do with
Russia
no why why do you ask that's a strange
question then again a month later a
young staffer would come up oh sir it's
such a pleasure to meet you sir oh
you're going to be such a great
president sir
were you involved with Russia I said
what the hell is going on with Russia
disinformation you know they're full of
discip that's what they are that's all
they're good at that stuff but it's
disinformation and then four or five
more times and I said I killed my people
I say could somebody explain what the
hell is going on with Russia and then I
see this sky on television being
interviewed one of Hillary Clinton's top
ponchos
and he said yeah yeah it was Russia
that's what it was it was Russia
you remember John love it's the liar on
a horrible show now but it used to be
good right it used to be good I actually
hosted it Saturday Night Live I hosted
it and two great ratings I might add but
I hosted that was before I ran for
politics after I read from politics they
weren't too interested and happy hosted
although I covered a lot of time and
Alec Baldwin's a sick puppy he was
terrible
I don't know I haven't seen the new guy
but I I hear he's better than Alec but
anybody would be you'd be anybody in the
front row
no it's true but uh
but that was not a not a very good not a
very good show it's become a very bad
show used to be a little bit funny but
this is pretty like uh kind of like a
verbal ink blot test even for Trump's
Meandering standards
now I think he's a sick person I've been
I've watched him he's a psycho something
happened there that's a strange deal
and he shouldn't have done those
interviews those interviews were that
good they were not good he goes lock
them up
and you may find that could be he is one
sick puppy just imprison anybody you
don't like and we're also for Law and
Order
164 million people working a record
never
right now now people are working and if
they're not working they take you off
the rolls and then they say what great
employment numbers you have that's not
true we achieved the largest poverty
reduction in 50 years and lifted 7
million people or food stamps and we
lifted 10 million people off of welfare
and they were happy they all had good so
just just to be thorough you guys know
that the labor participation rate stuff
is a total snow job by Republicans but
when Trump left office the labor force
participation rate was 61.4 percent and
it's now 62.2 percent so actually the
labor participation rate is up since
Trump left but when he was in charge did
a horrible job I said why is he going to
do good in this one he's the code n1h1
it's actually H it's easy to remember
because H comes before in right
Saudi H1N1 would also say things like
it's great to be with you in Florida
tonight thank you it's great there were
no palm trees no trees like look like
this
and he did that many many times you know
he'd be in Idaho and it's a Iowa if I
ever did it once I'd be dead
say it's over for him but you know by
the way one thing I have to say I love
Arnold Palmer yeah Trump never says
stuff like that we've endorsed JP right
JD Mandel drove because I knew him
really well the last 15 years of his
life and he was a great man he was
incredible do you know a story quick
about Arnold his father can I tell you a
quick story about Arnold Palmer
he was actually a sod carrier he was a
very strong person and Arnold Latrobe is
very close and Arnold was learned to
play using other people's clubs if they
had no money to buy a club and Arnold
would come in after hours and had used
members clubs and it learned and he
became great then he won the U.S amateur
isn't that an inspirational story from
the beginning he made a lot of money he
went back and he bought the course do
you know that he bought the course and
he put his father on a superintendent
and ultimately made his father the
manager of the club and he owned the
club right until his last day when he is
buried there his wife who he loved so
much I was with him as we walked past
where she was and he's Winnie Palmer is
an issue of major consequence for This
Crowd Oh man and I said so Arnold you
could be on the ocean you could be on
the west coast East Coast you could be
along the Potomac River you could be
anywhere you've decided to stay right
here he said I love this area I love
Pennsylvania and I love Latrobe so
there's a
amazing sir think of it he goes out and
he ends up buying it and makes his
father the boss I mean it's just it's
that's what our country is all I know a
lot of people are worried about this
woman here who seems to be visibly
shaking she's holding a little tiny kid
and and we could argue that the kid
shouldn't be there and we would be right
but she is she is shaking because she's
seems to be trying to rock a kid to
sleep
all my people want me to finance an
airplane he was buying an airplane
should I finance it I said well do you
need the money no I said then don't
Finance it in other words his instinct
is why do I finance an airplane if I
don't need the money but he loved
Pennsylvania and he loved this area a
lot of people in the crowd have had that
same dilemma Finance it or pay cash for
the airplane to be along the Pacific
Ocean the Atlantic Ocean or any other
ocean that he wanted and he didn't want
to move he never even thought about it
he was a great man and he's looking down
right now but he was a great man and he
loved your State under Biden four
million people have not returned to the
labor force real wages have declined 12
months in a row and the economy sucks
unemployments at a record low and the
labor participation rate is higher than
when Trump left
that first quarter and the fake news is
trying to say think
the economy went down for the first time
in many years and the fake news these
guys are look at all of them in the rain
they're standing it's all right-wing
media there they're standing in the rain
they're standing in the rain they should
stand and I'd like to have them in the
rain every every night I'd like them to
Bear the room
but Dave was saying I was watching the
fake news no the economy uh went down a
little bit but that's good news they're
the only ones that can say the economy
shrank
you know the economy shrank and it's
good news on covid which I call the
China virus because I want to be
accurate
we had tremendous tremendous success
with Therapeutics operations
nobody anywhere in the world did it like
us and I rejected mandates I rejected
unscientific lockdowns and I fought to
get our children the hell back in school
as soon as you can and
you know very importantly a lot of
people now are realizing this but I let
Republican Governors Run their states
the way they should be run without
interference from the federal government
but with a lot of help from the federal
government and getting ventilators and
Therapeutics and supplies of all shape
sizes and kinds to them without costs or
without delay and they've done an
incredible job a lot of the Republican
Governors have done
an incredible job you remember when
Governors get credit for doing this
great job which they really did the
Republican Governors did a tremendous
job and honestly the Democrat Governors
did a terrible job I can't think of one
that did good and I dealt with all of
them
and you know on the phone one would have
these weekly meetings with all the
governors 50 Governors then would have
these weekly meetings that Democrat goes
thank you so much for getting us to
vendor thank you I wish you could hear
these calls they actually do have
transcripts of all those calls but now
nobody cares unfortunately but they
would be so nice to me thank you sir
that you've done an incredible job this
afternoon's conference outside we're not
happy with the president
but we made them pay when we heard that
but it's because I let the Republican
Governors do what they wanted to do it
made it all possible for the great is he
going to hit transports today you guys
think that's been a big one for them
lately fantastic by contrast under Biden
more people died of covet last year than
all of 2020 they failed on testing they
failed on Therapeutics
and they impose horrific mandates
punishing lockdowns and radical mask
regulations
[Music]
[Applause]
what a gift from hell that was right
from China what a gift from hell and
don't forget I closed this down to China
we would have lost
perhaps hundreds of thousands of people
more thankfully a trump appointed judge
recently struck down Biden's ridiculous
mask mandate in a righteous victory
for American freedom
Joe Biden and the radical left Democrats
have turned calm into chaos chaos
confidence into incompetence and
stability into Anarchy that's the new
one chaos
and security into a catastrophe you look
at Afghanistan again and again we'll
never forget it that it would be nice if
they would talk about it they never talk
about it the fake news because it's so
horrific what happened
it was so bad they'd never talk about it
you really have to question I mean
honestly I'm sure this is a really nice
woman and smart and everything and and
you know everything but you've really
got to question the sanity of bringing a
little kid to a rally in the rain with
the fetid sanicans and the whole thing
and then now you're just you've gotta
you gotta
Rock and shaking on the whole thing to
try to get her to calm down
Jen is wonderful technology but it is
this beautiful
screens that I don't know how the hell
they're going to work in this rain but
we'll give it a shot but take a look at
this incredible scene
to watch thank you
television excuse me make sure you have
the record player on at night what am I
doing here
yeah this is where they visibly make fun
of Biden's stutter just openly
[Applause]
true International pressure isolated
punished China we owe these truth to be
civil evidence
all men and women created by the goal
you know this you know the thing so the
best way to get something done if you if
you hold a near and dear to you that you
uh
um like to be able to
way
we've enticed JP right JD Mandel no more
dropped by the Dropbox is a selfie
cephahide a rhino named Mitt Romney 12th
Central
Obama
then he went
Max silco and I've had more
investigations and Jesse James Billy the
could sue chin tendulker and God bless
the United States
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
but it's sad and he's surrounded by very
smart but vicious people that I really
believe hate our country I really
believe that
because they are smart people they're
vicious and they use law enforcement to
go after and Hunt people you see what
they're doing nobody's ever done
anything like they're doing he's
surrounded by these people and we have
to be victorious we're not going to have
a country left and once and for all Joe
Biden should
put the question to rest I don't think
we really need to know the answer
because we already do by taking a
cognitive test and releasing the results
for the entire world to see just like I
did here's the dementia rant I got tired
of these fake stories from these fake
reporters
that I took the test and uh Ronnie
Jackson dakarani right he's doc Ronnie
he's at BO Ronnie and he's now
Congressman Ronnie from Texas he's a
great man
and he was the doctor of bush
and Obama
who got us into the Middle East he did a
great job didn't he one of the worst
Presidents in our history whether you
like him or not whether you like a
Republican or not he got us into the
Middle East he should be ashamed of
himself for what he did and he never got
us out
and neither did Obama get us out
with the support of
all of these pictures that he should
take the test and by the way everybody
running for president should be forced
to take this test
you see that now
and I started by saying our country's at
the most dangerous point in history
that's so true and we have people some
of them maybe don't care others don't
get it they're not into the world of
deals or psychology or dealing with
other people trumps into the world of
deals and psychology now they're all
bragging about what they did
let Ukraine take the credit but you got
to get out they got to make a deal got
to make a deal Russia is going to make a
deal they would make a deal Ukraine
should make a deal there's not a lot
left though you know the uh the time to
do it was at the beginning before it
started
it would have never happened even if
they didn't make a deal it would have
never happened I spoke to Putin about it
a lot
and I told them what would happen if it
did and he understood that and we never
had you know a lot of people they say
actually a lot of the radical left say
we agree that if Trump were president
that would not have happened that's just
such a horrible thing
but they knew that it was not something
that was going to and the fact is for
four years it didn't happen it's never
even thought about nor did Taiwan happen
with President XI of China that didn't
happen
with the support of all the Patriots
here tonight we saved our country once
and together we will save our country
again
if you're wondering why they're not
showing the whole crowd this is the
whole crowd
I won twice let's check these much
better the second time than I did the
first time getting 12 million more votes
than we did
into scene and
then any president in the history of our
country votes by millions than any
president in the history of our country
other than Biden by far and now we may
have to do it again
and I hope hope all of you can go out
and see something that I think is genius
it's really amazing it just came out the
night before last it opened it had a
Premiere in a Florida beautiful house
small little place a quench place called
Mar-A-Lago
and we had over a thousand people very
important people and you know they'll
try and suppress it as much as possible
but it's determinative definitive
whatever word you want to use you know
they like to use determinative that
means election changing definitive
election changing or just say it was
election changing probably but I hope
you can see the genius of Dinesh
d'souza's incredible new documentary
it's called 2 000 mules
and basically it's about ballot
trafficking get the ballots okay in a
sense
but it's an incredible it's an
incredible documentary I mean if if the
people that do this stuff is were fair
this would get every award there'd be
nothing even close this exposes the
fraud like the cinematography is just
incredible the lighting off because they
say there he goes again and by the way
if I didn't go we would lose a lot of
our base you know somebody came up to me
the other day and they said sir I'd like
to thank you for something what you
never conceded thank God you never can
say that I
think of it now that's a total total red
meat claim like his audience thinks it
matters if he concedes and of course it
makes no difference
and these people that say sir
sir
it doesn't matter sir you're leading by
30 points you're up 70 80 points in the
Republican primary nobody's close and
you're leading by I guess some poll came
out I'm leaving him by like 15 16 points
who the hell wouldn't be give me a break
this person right here did you ever run
for politics no you would be leading by
more than me
I once ran for ethics you know they're
friends they're good people they're good
rhinos you know we have good rhinos too
by them not too many of them but they'll
say sir
it doesn't matter what happened you're
gonna win the next time we may not have
a country the next time
so do the polls matter or don't they I'm
confused Libby would have to say in four
years now we're down to less than two
and a half years it's starting to get
very reasonable it's starting to get
very reasonable and in November
do you have the midterms coming and you
know we're going through the primers
right now
so far the numbers that we're putting up
are incredible and I take that with
great pride because is he going to bring
up Oz you would think so not me and you
know we endorse a lot of people here we
go a little bit out of the box you know
they said well does he endorse Front
Runners down JD was not leading and they
put it we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel
crap just like they're doing with us the
same thing they're spending millions and
millions and millions of dollars and
they're trying to hurt him so badly I
just think he's going to win he's a
great gentleman I've known him so long
and we endorsed JD and he was like a
rocket ship he went peeing it didn't
make any difference it didn't make any
difference to them all the ads they hit
him that last week as hard as any human
being
has ever been hit
sort of like Abdul would have been hit
but he decided he was very smart Abdul
said to me you know he said but sir why
why'd you send me a picture of my home
insurance
[Applause]
true
I sent him a beautiful picture actually
this is quite a nice place
one of our most
urgent priorities when Republicans we
take Congress must be to end the
nightmare on the southern border which
is one of the most horrible things that
ever happened to our country where our
country is being poisoned weakened and
permanently stained
illegal aliens are pouring in by the
millions and millions and millions
nobody knows what the number is they say
two million three million I think it's
15 million and it's only going to get
worse and they want to get rid of some
of the remaining things we had remain in
Mexico how good is that you think that
was easy to get
right I went to the state department I
said give me the top 10 things I went to
the border patrol and the ice people the
officials I said give me your top 15
things your top 10 things I'll get them
all from Mexico they laughed at me
everybody laughed border patrol these
guys are so incredible by the way and I
S and they gave me the list
and somebody at the State Department of
woman she was fantastic she worked on
Mexico for 25 years she said sir you'll
never get this we've been asking for
this for many many years I said max
silicone I will they say Sir you'll
never get it sure I had little things
like you have to remain in Mexico you
can't come into our country we want 28
000 people to guard our border as we're
building the border wall 28 000 soldiers
they said sir we never even asked for
that part that's ridiculous so you'll
never get it I say 100 you're gonna get
it 100 I would bet you any amount but of
course I don't want to be Mitt Romney
when he said I'll bet you ten thousand
do you remember that disasters now
I did say
if Trump runs there's nobody that can
beat him he did say that the name Mitt
Romney hey he's coming along I think Dr
Oz could say that that was shocking Mitt
Romney said that but I said to them I
said that the officials came in from
Mexico very handsome beautiful people
they came in in a kid this type of being
all over the place would be potentially
a factor where you're like oh we should
consider ADHD
and then I said you're gonna have to do
remain in Mexico and you're gonna have
to do eight other things that were
almost as bad and they laughed and
smiled they said we would never do it
this is a really long story you have to
do it you will do it they said we're not
going to do it sir I said here's what's
going to happen this was a Friday
afternoon I said on Monday morning at
eight o'clock in the morning we're going
to charge you 25 tariffs on every car
right and everything you make from
Mexico that comes into our country and
we're going to take in billions and
billions and billions of dollars and
it's going to more than pay for whatever
we have to do to secure our border
and he said may we call the president
yes and he came back about five minutes
later he said sir it would be a great
honor
to give you 28 000 soldiers free it
would be a great honor sir for you to
allow
millions of people potentially to stay
in Mexico as they await clearance into
the United States which not too many
people got now we had it really really
incredible we did an incredible job and
we got everything and the person from
the state department came over said sir
that was the most amazing thing I've
ever seen in government I said actually
it was quite easy as I told you it would
be when Republicans retake Congress we
should immediately pass legislation to
ban the federal government from
unloading plane loads and plane loads
and truckloads and everything else of
illegal aliens and American communities
and
into our homeland this is our homeland
that we love and we cherish our country
is full we can't take it anymore they
are trying to destroy our country we
can't let that happen in addition to
Illegal immigration Biden is blown out
the refugee cap what a blowout 800
percent plus think of that we had a cap
on the number of people that could come
into our country he's 800 percent above
the cap and that doesn't include the
ones that come in Legally which is
frankly most of them
including bringing in tens of thousands
of unvetted unscreened foreign Nationals
from Afghanistan on the plains that's
not happening hundreds of thousands of
people and only three percent qualified
to come in some of them are terrorists
I've been very good at predicting did
you ever hear that I've been very good
you're going to be paying for that we
are all going to be paying that for many
years to come
Republicans should vote to restore my
strong policy prohibiting Refugee
resettlement without the approval of
local governments under the defund the
police Mantra they wanted to fund the
police
[Music]
foreign
which is all of them democrat-run cities
are also being ravaged remember that
cities generally speaking are run by
democrats Democrats in general prefer to
be in cities the high crime cities are
run by democrats and the low crime
cities are run by democrats where
frankly I went to college a very
wonderful place called The Wharton
School of Finance last year Philadelphia
broke all records for murders listen to
this this is an American city with
562 homicides
562. that's a war zone that's not a city
it's a 32 year old woman
who was seven months pregnant was gunned
down outside her home as she unloaded
gifts from her baby shower
a few weeks ago in Pittsburgh a 15 year
old boy was left dead after being shot
in the head
while riding his bicycle down the street
and in March 50 bullets were fired into
a crowded Pittsburgh Party leaving two
people dead eight others Gravely wounded
dying most of them
and still more badly injured when they
jumped out of Windows to escape the
slaughter they jumped out of Windows
they were so badly injured
Democrats are the party of crime
the party of chaos and the party of
death they are whether you hate saying
it or like saying it they're the party
of death Republicans are the party of
law order and life
[Music]
and you know what else the Republicans
are
they're the party of the American dream
they really are they're the party of the
American dream which is being taken away
from you if you want to make our country
safer for violent criminals vote for the
radical Democrats if you want to make it
safer for your family your children and
for law abiding Americans you must vote
for Republicans you must
really a big focus on Dr Oz here huh
which is sort of like the whole point of
the rally it's with the Hispanics
African-Americans Asian Americans
everybody the party is a much different
party than it was when I started
six years ago six years ago really and
we have a much different party
we have a party some people say trumpism
call it whatever you want but it is
indeed a party Trump certainly prefers
you call it trumpisms right here in
Pennsylvania that starts with nominating
to win Pennsylvania's U.S Senate race
this fall my friend Dr Mehmet Oz he's a
great man
Dr Oz I've known him a long time his
show is I said he's in that
he's on that screen he's in the bedrooms
of all those women telling them good and
bad
and they love him he came into a place
where we had a lot of women sitting
there waiting for something unrelated
they started going crazy is that Dr Oz
that's Dr Ross something unrelated but
he's uh taking a lot of
horrible Trump was with Oz somewhere
where there were women waiting for
something unrelated Street people have
plenty of money
plenty of money they're spending
millions of dollars and treating them
very unfairly Dr Oz has led an
enormously successful career on
television and now he's running to save
our country just like I do
from the radical left lunatics and
maniacs
Dr Oz is a man who
truly believes in make America great
again or the Maga movement and we will
men men of the country
he's supported by Sean Hannity and we
all love Sean Hannity Rick Perry
and very importantly he's supported by
somebody known as me he's supported by
me
oh my God is this kid okay
as your Senator Oz will fight against
illegal immigration and Sanctuary cities
and put dangerous criminals Behind Bars
that's what he wants to do is this gonna
seizure gonna stop the Democrat
socialists and Communists and confront
China like no senator in the history of
our state and by the way you have a
senator who is very weaker in China this
guy to me I wouldn't give him my
endorsement so he couldn't run
this guy to me is so bad on China I just
realized this guy's wearing a helmet
question Pat just let me ask you this
question a stupid question China's been
ripping us off for many years you've
done nothing about it
if they're charging us a hundred percent
tariff are we allowed to charge them a
hundred percent tough no sir let's not
pre-trade sure are we allowed to judge
him 50 Pat no
25
no can't judge him anything I say
there's something wrong with this guy
this is your Senator and I wouldn't give
him and by the way he knew that you know
he raised his hand to impeach me and if
I would have said I would have given him
the nod I would have given him a
nomination he would have never raised
his hand which tells you I have a
certain courage but I also believed a
lot in the other Senators that we happen
to have Republican Senators but he
wanted me to endorse him and I couldn't
do it because he was so bad on trade he
was given our country away to China and
others Dr Oz is running against the
liberal Wall Street Republican named
David McCormick who I've known
and David's another one in all fairness
and he will say this he fought hard for
it he wanted it he hired almost every
person that worked anywhere if anybody
was within 200 miles of me he hired them
but he didn't want my endorsement very
badly but I just couldn't do it I
couldn't do it I know them both
and you have some other very good people
I know him but I I know in particular
these two people and uh they're leading
they're both leading
but I have to say Oz is leading by more
despite this tremendous oddslaught
Paul just came out he's up by three or
four points
David came out very strongly against me
on numerous occasions this was before he
was going to run all of a sudden he said
boy I like this guy a lot
including with respect to the
disinformation spread about January 6th
total disinformation remember about
January 6 if I might I am the one who
strongly requested ten thousand military
soldiers or National Guard to Nancy
Pelosi and the mayor of DC on January
3rd three days early because she's in
charge of the capital both of them and
she and the mayor turned it down they
didn't want it Secretary of Defense
offered it to him they turned it down
they were in charge they could have it
or not
if they had listened to me and my
recommendation there would have been no
January 6 and the unselect committee of
Highly partisan political hacks and
losers would never have been chosen it
should never be going on right now
because we offered to have 10 000
soldiers circling the capital so you
would have never had a problem but they
turned it down and now they're saying
conspiracy he doesn't love our country I
love the country so much more than they
did and much more for this country than
they have
wow so I don't know David well
and he may be a nice guy but he's not
Maga he's not Maga
he's more to me than he is back at
[Applause]
least I do know that he was with a
company that managed money for communist
China
and he is absolutely the candidate of
special interests and globalists and the
Washington establishment and those who
are the people that are not only
spending millions and millions of
dollars on his campaign they have
unlimited money to just try and destroy
us
but they want to destroy this great
warrior and a truly nice person not
going to do it
and they're also the people that are
ripping off the United States with the
bad trade deals open borders and every
other thing that the people in this
audience will never stand for and you
fully reject
David is totally controlled this is the
opponent
by Mitch McConnell the old crow the old
broken down Crow
Mitch McConnell is the least popular
politician in the country according to
the but no he's an old broken down
Pro I want to be nice I don't want to
come oh
add that word right out it's open season
on Republicans huh I'd go home and the
first lady would say why didn't you
didn't use that foul language darling I
love you so much but why did she said
sir is it all broken down pizza Crow
[Applause]
no but David fits in with him I mean
they gave away this 1.9 trillion dollars
for an infrastructure deal
to the Democrats I call it
infrastructure because there's virtually
no infrastructure Liz Cheney Adam
kinzinger Mitt Romney and all of the
other rhinos that are trying to destroy
our party
and destroy our country fit in so nicely
with David McCormick that's the way it
is
and we can't let it happen
he will quickly fold to the fake news
David he's going to follow McCormick is
he going to bring Oz on this is a
strange rally left Democrats that's the
way it is and that's the way he is ours
will never do that he will fight till
the end and he will always have you back
we can always count on Dr Oz again I
know him well he uh did an interview
with me on a show I did a show years ago
and he said uh I want to do like a
physical on you I said that's okay just
like Biden and everybody running for
president should take a cognitive test
he wanted to do a physical I felt great
so he did it physically he came out with
a great report he said he's very healthy
he's really great great but he should
lose some weight I said that's not good
that's not good you had to say that Oz
didn't you huh you had to say that you
could have been perfect
I would have liked him even more if he
said he's really really healthy and is
one of the greatest bodies I've ever
seen remember Trump claims to be six
foot three and to weigh only 239 pounds
I think excuse me you can find athletes
that are 6'3
uh 239 and you'll notice they don't look
like Trump
[Applause]
do we love president Trump Pennsylvania
has Joe Biden made us miss him even more
the only thing Joe Biden has built back
better is the Republican Party
that President Trump leads he sees The
Shining City on the hill he sees it here
in the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania he's
fighting to save it but he's fighting
for more when you save the soul of
Pennsylvania you see the soul of America
and the rest of the world is watching us
they see a controlling authoritarian
surveillance China they see democracy
giving rise to capitalism that President
Trump made function so beautifully just
15 months ago seems surreal that has
been ruined so quickly that's what we're
fighting for that's why president trump
it means the world to me that you're
here sir God bless you
and thank you for the endorsement
he really has it down 45 seconds mostly
praising Trump otherwise Trump gets
bored and annoyed
thank you Oz
thank you he didn't need this just like
I didn't have to be here tonight at this
horrible rainstorm
our first lady said are you crazy do it
a different day I said I'm not gonna let
those people down they've been there for
four days
we're not letting him down we're never
gonna let him down
so the primary is on May 17th but early
voting begins this Tuesday May 10th get
out and vote early voting which he's
against the fake news crying tears of
Despair on Election night just like they
did
again we did so much better the second
time but they were very upset the first
time but they all said we're never going
to let that happen again they may let it
happen again
vote for Dr Oz he's an outstanding
person
we're also joined by representatives and
these are warriors these are friends of
mine and run up here and say a couple of
words come here John Joyce
representative Trump doesn't have Mike
Kelly
Alex Moody Alex is in a big race that's
one of the Races they keep saying is
Mooney gonna win because Mooney is being
backed by Trump and he's got a an
opponent but I think Mooney's gonna do
real well and the next congressman from
Pennsylvania's eighth congressional
district Jim bognet come in Jim come on
also State Treasurer Stacy Garrity Stacy
come on up
great job she did she said sir I must
tell you sure it's first time in many
years that a Republicans won right she
said sir I won because of you I like
this super chat I am honestly ashamed to
say I had no idea Trump's content was so
radical and dangerous
you are much more popular and you lost
my area you lost this it's not possible
and I appreciate you saying that because
I happen to like you more than unlike me
okay but no but a lot of people said it
the election was rigged it was a
disgrace and my quiz my great anybody
know what he's talking about
of business
again I want to introduce the man who
really I mean honestly if the movie
world were legit he'd get every award
you could probably
the Academy Awards used to get good
ratings remember the Academy Awards in
the old days before they started
knocking us and Trump and mega now they
had like a regular show but he would get
everything for this documentary Dinesh
to Susan didn't that's just come up
please come up oh God if you want to
talk about a dangerous guy Dinesh
D'Souza is exactly it with us are some
friends of mine they wanted to say I
said don't come tonight let's go another
time it's pouring Woody Johnson a great
gentleman you ever hear of Johnson and
Johnson he owns the place I tell you
what this guy's got cash like nobody's
got cash yeah Johnson and Johnson his
incredible wife Suzanne Johnson whose
family is very very
close and she comes from Ukraine so
she's uh she has a little bit of a hard
time with it but she's an incredible
woman what another incredible woman is
Summers Farkas a person respected by
everybody in New York so I want to thank
you all wherever you may be thank you
Woody thank you very much this is
getting weird Terrible Weather I said
Woody let's wait for a really beautiful
day it's pouring out here with the help
of many people here tonight
over four years and incredible years we
all stood up for Pennsylvania so I'd
like to ask just a couple of you to come
up and say a couple of words you're
running against somebody that you should
be easily sorry I hit my measly or I'm
going to look very bad they're going to
say Trump has lost it say uh say a few
words
well thank you president Trump for
coming here and lending your support the
Republican primary in West Virginia is
Tuesday May 10th so again please tell
your friends and family to vote May 10th
it's important we win these primaries to
have real Republicans that'll fight like
Donald Trump did for the values that we
all share thank you and God bless
I was thinking about coming in a
beautiful suit like that but I couldn't
do it I didn't
didn't want to waste all that money and
ruin that [ __ ] where's my Mike say a
couple of weeks been my friend from day
one
thank you Mr President
there is another there's no other time
in our history that we have been tested
like we are being tested it's actually
getting funny now
four years under President Trump we saw
America grow not just in our economy but
in respect around the world that's a lie
you were never tested we were now
wanted to Bama hurricane we now have
somebody in the White House that nobody
fears nobody respects and people can't
imagine how they were able to pull off
the greatest seal in American history in
the election
I thank God every night that I had the
opportunity as an American citizen to
serve under this President and I pray
that we have the opportunity again God
bless you all for being here and refuse
to lose just refuse to lose
very sick man
well that's a pretty good job would you
say he's a good politician you know the
fact is
he's not a politician he's a man that
really believes in what he's doing he
really believes it I'd like to ask thank
you Mike I'd like to ask the treasurer
to come up and just say a little bit
about what you saw that evening because
it was an incredible thing and I've
heard that from a lot of people oh no
look at this
thank you
so I'm
I'm at a Republican treasure in 20 years
the first time a republican be a
Democrat incumbent since 1988 and I have
president Donald J Trump so thank for
that he gave me three shout outs I spoke
at two of the rallies I love the pledge
it was incredible and
um we know that he won
so he pushed a lot of us over the Finish
Line I am forever grateful she was
supposed to explain all of the fraud she
saw ain't we need you know a republican
Governor we need a republican lieutenant
governor and a Republican senator my
friend Dr Oz
God bless you
thank you very much and great job you've
done so thank you did she explain the
fraud she saw I didn't hear it thank you
Mike good job thank you everybody
with the help of many people here
tonight over four years incredible years
they were we stood up for Donald J Trump
that was amazing history
to protect our workers I withdrew from
the horrible trans-pacific partnership
would have destroyed your businesses we
ended the disaster known as NAFTA the
worst trade deal ever made
we replace it with the usmca that's
Mexico and Canada the best trade deal
ever made the same thing we stood up to
China like never before taking in
billions and billions of dollars yeah
responsible for some of what we're
seeing here that's an interesting super
chop billions think of it and we gave
many times more than this number we gave
28 billion dollars of it to our great
Farmers we love our Farmers many in
Pennsylvania
and to protect Pennsylvania energy
workers I withdrew from the unfair Paris
climate Accord a ripoff
I canceled Obama's falsely named clean
power plan which was a disaster other
than the name of the plan it was a total
disaster I ended the war on Pennsylvania
Oil and Gas and I ended the war on clean
beautiful coal we put our miners back to
work we fought for Pennsylvania and we
won for Pennsylvania and when we win in
this November this coming this coming
midterm which I think maybe will be the
most important in our country's history
we will fight and win for Pennsylvania
and our country itself because our
country is in serious trouble we will
win and we will stop this horrible
horrible onslaught with the Republican
Congress we must defend parents rights
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children
without parents
we will save our kids and we will also
keep men the hell out of women's sports
foreign
we will get critical race Theory out of
our schools out of our military and out
of every part of our federal state
and local governments you know I had
done that and then just about in his
first day in office he
wrote an executive office ending it but
we had already done that it was gone got
rid of all of them one of our highest
priorities will be to crack down on
left-wing censorship and restore free
speech in America we don't have free
speech we don't have free speech and we
have a totally crooked press all of them
back there we will immediately terminate
Joe Biden's so-called disinformation
governing board how about that one
chilling and Un-American I'm hoping that
he's winding down
allow to stand
go out and sign up now for by the way
truth truth I'm so happy to be back on
social media truth essential on the
Apple App Store number one ahead of tick
tock Facebook Twitter and all others
number one can you believe it I opened
this thing it's like we got we have
really a great platform but number one
what a great honor it was to look at
that
is going to be our voice it's going to
be the voice of the people and by the
way Jason Miller I want to introduce
Jason Miller he's a great friend of
mine's done a fantastic job and he also
has a big voice out there on the social
media wherever he may be Jason wherever
you are this big crowd of people
Jason thank you essential thank you
I'm glad I remembered to do that
the radical left Democrat Party is not a
50 party within our country I really
believe that they're against God Guns
oil law enforcement voter ID the
Constitution and the founding fathers
other than that they're wonderful
the only way they win is to cheat at
elections I really believe that you
can't be against those things and think
you're a 50 50 party
we have to restore election Integrity in
our country
in 20
16 we won Pennsylvania by a lot
from that point 2016 to 2020 Republicans
outregistered because of me to a large
extent Democrats in Pennsylvania listen
to this
21-1 that never happened before we
outregistered them 21-1
which is why on Election night we were
up by more than 650
000 votes it was over
and that's one of those things where
it's like I've never heard that before
it strikes me as unlikely that that
Republicans outregistered Democrats 21-1
in any place but like I've never heard
that I don't know where do you even look
that up could drop boxes they're fake
and no private money pouring into local
election offices no Dropbox is it just
like in France we just had a
and we got to view a big election that
just took place
we should have one day voting with only
paper ballots yeah macron defeated Trump
light did military service members
distant if they're not in the country or
people who are very very sick
it should last one day what about these
elections that last 48 days where they
have boxes and boxes and they're in
they're in rooms in storage nobody
watching over them they're being moved
all over the place you say what's going
on one day paper ballots One Day
election paper ballots like we used to
have
we have a process that nobody trusts and
you can't have a great country if nobody
trusts the elections and most Americans
actually do trust it
we're just six months away from the most
important midterm victory in American
history and we need a landslide so big
that the radical left cannot rig it or
steal it
you know at a certain point if you
wouldn't buy enough they can't rig it
but we're also watching them very
closely more closely than ever before
this is the year we're going to take
back the house we're going to take back
the Senate and we are going to take back
America
and in 2024 most importantly we are
going to take back our beautiful White
House
cutting to the wrap up huh
but first we have to secure a massive
victory for Dr Oz in this primary so get
your friends
get your family get everyone you know
and get the hell out to vote for Dr Oz
you got to do it
I want to thank JD Vance for being here
by the way what a job he did teach he's
hot now you know he's hot he's a great
hot celebrity baby you Won't Remember Me
Anymore maybe he'll say Trump oh yeah he
was all right but he will he's gonna
remember all of us because he's going to
be around for a long long time
politically in my opinion very smart and
he's the one that can win and he will
win he will win in Ohio
we got to work really hard to make sure
Tim Ryan defeats JD Vance in Ohio people
of Ohio really stepped forward they did
a great job
with the Republican Congress
we will fight for more jobs for
Pennsylvania families fair trade for
Pennsylvania workers and more
Pennsylvania factories forging more
products stamped with those beautiful
words made in the USA
we will shut down Biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong
remaining Mexico policy
we will reimpose title 42 which I
understand their ending
you want to see people come into our
country knock out title 42. strengthen
the Patriots of ice and Border Patrol
and we will again end Catch and Release
we will end chain migration a disaster
we will end aren't melania's parents
here because of chain migration
the remaining portion of the wall
could have been done in a few weeks we
will stop the Democrat crime wave we
will give our police the power they need
and the respect they deserve
and I want to thank the Pennsylvania
police for the treatment they've given
me I love the police they do a great job
they're not given
the kind of accolades they should get
every single day it's dangerous work and
they do an incredible job but we will
not take legal protection ever away from
them they want to take legal protection
so if they happen to make a mistake or
somebody sues them they have to protect
themselves that's not going to happen we
will restore Law and Order In America we
will hold China accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world we
will protect innocent life we will
defend our Constitution and we will
defend the Second Amendment
we will proudly uphold the
judeo-christian values and principles of
our Nations founding
[Music]
and by the way very importantly as you
know during that term records almost 300
federal judges and three justices of the
Supreme Court of the he's right about
that that's a major accomplishment for
uh Republicans during Trump's era and it
is thanks to Trump being in office
there's no doubt about that children to
love their country honor our history and
always respect our Great American flag
in conclusion our Maga movement make
America great again is by far the
greatest political movement in the
history of our country and the fake news
can't even challenge it
can't even think of it I've said it many
times that they've never challenged it
because it's the greatest movement in
the history of our country and probably
it's too dumb to challenge yeah
and against some of the most menacing
forces entrenched interests and vicious
opponents our people have ever seen
despite great outside dangers and we do
have tremendous outside dangers and
right now more than ever before because
our so-called leaders I say so-called
they don't know what the hell they're
doing or how to deal with it
but despite that our biggest threat
Remains the sick
Sinister demented and evil people that
we have from within
but no matter how big or powerful these
corrupt radicals may be you must never
forget this nation does not belong to
them this nation belongs to you
belongs to you
[Applause]
and I do want to thank you all for
coming out of this unbelievable weather
I want to thank me too you know because
I said I could have had a I could have
hey Oz I could have had a great out
I could have had and by the way your
wife is so incredible you're going to
get a great first lady in the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania you're
going to get a first lady I know her
well she's incredible and and does she
love her family her husband and her
family so thank you very much for being
here and standing especially the first
lady standing uh standing with us thank
you very much
hernage and our American Liberty is your
god-given right his use of Heritage is a
little bit a little bit concerning to
Erie
from Harrisburg to
[Music]
Pichu poured out their Blood Sweat and
Tears for our rights and for our freedom
Pennsylvania is the Commonwealth where
our founding fathers
declared American Energy Independence
think of that you're the first ones many
many many years ago
who would think where we are we had it
done a year and a half ago and today
we're begging for energy we're begging
enemies for energy it's where the Army
weathered its brutal winter at Valley
Forge
where General George Washington LED his
men in a daring Mission across the
Delaware and where our Union was saved
by The Immortal Heroes at Gettysburg
Gettysburg Pennsylvania
one of the most
vicious battles in history and one of
the most beautiful places on Earth isn't
that interesting
crowd is dead and this is the state
where generations of tough strong
Pennsylvania miners Factory workers and
Steel Workers forged the greatest nation
in the history of the world
at least he didn't read that stupid poem
The Snake who built this country and it
is the hard-working Patriots like you
who are going to save our country from
what's happening right now we will stand
up to the radical left lunatics and the
rhinos and we will fight for America
like no one has ever fought for a
country before
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no Summit we cannot reach there
is no challenge we cannot meet there is
no Victory we cannot have
we will not Bend we will not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up we will never ever
ever ever back down
as long as trumpet roughly the 73 minute
Mark right now I do not stand even a
small chance of victory
because we are Americans and Americans
kneel to God and to God Alone
my fellow citizens this incredible
journey we are on together has only just
begun it's just begun
and Oz is going to help us
to have it keep going
ours is going to help us
and it's time to start talking about
greatness for our country again we don't
do that we don't do that we don't talk
about greatness anymore we talk about
everything else
We Are One movement one people one
family and one glorious Nation
under God
so with the help of everyone here today
and citizens all across our land it
really is a cult America powerful again
we will make America wealthy again we
will make America strong again we will
make America proud again
we will make America safe again and we
will make America great again thank you
Pennsylvania thank you very much thank
you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well if you suffered through all 75
minutes of it congratulations folks you
just won the election uh I don't know
how else to say
oh is the mix not okay am I too not not
loud enough
blacks for Trump with a presence here
just off screen seemingly
um let me know if this week there are
various debates and things related to
2022 I I try to plan ahead and when I
know about it ahead of time we'll
publish it ahead of time
um but if you know of any important 2022
debates and events this week please do
email and info at davidpackman.com we'll
get it on the calendar so everybody
knows I'll be streaming
uh
uh okay so yeah there's Trump
wow there is no I believe there is no
Johnny Depp trial this coming week I
think they're off for a week for
whatever reason
don't really know why but
all right so there goes president Trump
the failed former president
bit of a different uh
apparel today
it's weird it's a weird country
all right
well there he goes thank you everybody
appreciate everybody uh joining me today
I don't know what we learned other than
the cult is strong
and
um what what else did we learn people in
chat what can you tell me
can can anybody think please tell me we
learned something we're not in a good
place that's true
we learned about John old Trump that
we're screwed
that they think they own this country
that's fair
we didn't learn anything oh okay geez
that's that's tragic all right everybody
thank you for joining me uh we will see
everybody
soon before you know it